[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
what's up
oh
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
oh
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
what's up champ
good to see you bud buster bud
um
yep
thanks for coming out yeah skipper
thanks for joining cheers uh it's good
to be here cheers we got our coffees
it's an honor truly dude thank you so
much for coming out i really appreciate
it hey i mean thanks for coming on down
to the show
yeah yeah yeah
your producers are all really nice you
know the group i was hanging out in the
green room they got so much crafty
crazy it's a big production it looks
like a house but actually a studio
exactly we have lots of pretzel thins um
and hummus yeah lots of varieties they
have the uh sour cream and onion
ketchup flavor absolutely thank you all
for joining us today um hopefully you
can see us and hear us um i'm clint on
this side
and that's peter
and that side nice to meet you um the
audio what
oh i think the audio sounds pretty darn
good based off of my level oh no it
sounds too good
audio sensitivity is a little too high
cuts off your voices well we'll just
talk a little louder
um and we're gonna make it great we're
gonna lean in a little bit oh yeah you
know scoot on in get yourself nice and
comfy yeah audio's clipping
clip audio meeting
oh
all right so here here's what it is it's
probably one of them things get up in
there
oh we got a we got a super chat from
david bloom thank you thanks dude david
i appreciate you very much very very
much
um
freaking awesome sodamonte says the
audio is good so we're we're trusting
the moderator here we're trusting the
stream producer
like soda that we're looking good we
just need to talk a little bit louder i
think that's i can do that yeah that's
easy
um so what are we doing today y'all
over
the last month
um i challenged everybody to
the render challenge really honestly
that's what that's why we're here we're
here to check out uh
we're gonna take a look at all the top
100 best renders from the dynamic
machines render challenge there's going
to be three us winners and three
international winners
um
so it's gonna be pretty sweet we're
gonna do a little bit differently than
last time last time we went through we
broke it down um and we like
raised everyone up to like
level two and level three level four and
we went over the renders five and six
times we're just gonna go through the
renders one time we're gonna go through
all 100 and we're just going to talk
about how sick they are because they
truly deserve to be talking about like
it's not like oh this one didn't make it
because it wasn't this it wasn't that no
no
all of these are sick we're gonna talk
about how cool they are dude i've seen
some they're all incredible yeah
and most of them have sound design too
so it's gonna be sweet um we're gonna go
through all 100 and we're just gonna go
back to uh third place second place
first place and announce it right here
they're gonna win some really really
sick stuff what do they win it that's a
great question do you have anything from
pmy i've heard they're really cool
that is very true yo shout outs here let
me see i got this shout outs to pny
nvidia for sponsoring um the dynamic
machines render challenge this is the
third challenge
um this is the second one they've
sponsored
and they're throwing out some awesome
prizes we got an nvidia quadro rtx 5000
for uh first place
for the us
um we have a one terabyte pcie m2 nvme
ssd for second place
wow read and write speeds through the
roof and then for third place us we have
a 2.5 inch sata 3 ssd from p and y and
then
shout outs to them
yeah good times good times um super
chill to work with um working on that
that uh quadro a6000 card and it is
absolutely ridiculous shout outs to
good times now if you're an
international winner because
these prizes can only be shipped out to
the us
um i got you guys hooked up with three
art prints limited edition art prints um
and a full year of my patreon pro tier
access oh
it's going down we're doing it um ahmed
got us tia thanks for the super chat
thanks for the challenge dude thanks for
uh thanks for the support and i hope you
had a good time on the challenge tapes
on my back
got out for that super chat let's go
nice stream everybody good times good
times
and uh i think we're just about ready to
do this um are you ready
after this sip
is sky captain is skycap1 skycap or
captain captain
cap
i'll take it
audio's clipping
voice cancellation problem we're too
enthusiastic gate a little too high you
know what i'll trust i'll trust mike is
cutting out a little bit
let's see what we can do
oh you got a noise gate going on
yeah here tell me how this works
do i need to they said it's cutting our
voices off do i need to
close the threshold
we test test test what's at the closed
threshold below
oh it's sodo photo what's going on
interesting we can just
uh we could
maybe that's better
yeah
sweet that's better yeah it just like
takes out the audio sounds fine audio
sounds great hey work it's a good time
everybody it's hard to judge it when you
can't hear it but um soto we got you on
the speakers um
so maybe people can hear you maybe they
can't
but
here we go y'all let's do it switching
over we're gonna get up into da vinci
and it's time to check out these top 100
renders
it's freaking doing so excited it's just
like
an hour of eye candy absolutely
jesus wow
damn let's take a look at that again
yeah let's go back that's awesome
so this is coming from romaine
miller
all right
and the other the strokes on there the
line line strokes yeah i really dig the
like paper look they have here it's like
you got the animated look it looks
really cool yeah um they got the ball
coming in it like it's all chrome and
then it switches to paper world
they got people in here too oh that's
great it's a lot of work because they
have to do different lines for each
surface for over the course of time they
had to paint individual frames for it
for real it's pretty sweet
that's awesome
super freaking cool romaine great job i
love your style
it's really good
one last time
that's hot the little strokes yeah and
and like in the way that like
he blurs the ball you see he stretches
the ball out right here yeah yeah
yeah
super sick
shout out to romaine um
all right next up
raghuvan whoa
[Music]
that's great oh my god they have the
corridor crew back there yup
they got the crew and then oh my god
there's ness up here there's bowser over
here this was made for you son it kind
of was all your favorite things it's
pretty sweet
one more time let's take a look that's
great from india shout outs great sound
design
it's so satisfying i want to just like
keep throwing marbles at that thing i
know getting all them points yeah very
sick
good work rav ragavanch
hopefully i'm saying that right
um from india good stuff very good stuff
all right what do we got next we got uh
from indonesia
uh fadin
they got the corrugated uh like interior
of the cardboard like in between the the
pieces yep like the bent paper right
here yeah even just like falling off a
little bit really good lighting really
good color yeah it feels tangible
the detail like the the layers of
construction paper overlapping and stuff
wow
taking out that robot oh wait so it's a
bomber it's a bombing run it's a bombing
oh my god that's great yeah wow that's
awesome
yeah super sick
great sound design too yeah that's
really fun dig the clouds i love how
everything's attached too like is that
it looks like it's actually built from
one thing it's like on a paper clip
oh is it it's like very grounded in
reality at least this one yeah yeah i
love that either there's tape on here
like this could actually work um shout
outs uh guilherme
um
apologies if i got that wrong thanks for
the super chat uh choose from brazil
heck yeah dude you rock appreciate you
man
very nice very nice
all right let's um let's move on who do
we got next uh from indonesia again we
got rice
god that's so cute very nice
i love the lights it feels very cozy
dude let's hit these lights
beautiful perfect
wow
makes me miss carnivals i know that's
really nice
it's so interesting how you can like
like get across the idea of a carnival
and like the aesthetic without actually
showing a real carnival
yeah it's like these like the it's all
the lights turning on and flickering on
and stuff and the the color like the the
strips of color
it's really nice
really cool little slide and wheel you
got going there
good stuff from indonesia shout outs
all right great job bryce moving on
i love that
oh man lego town
the dopamine center of my brain is just
going to
yeah so much detail on that i miss legos
i'm such a big lego kid me too man
can i did you did you mess with connects
or i messed with connects a little bit
yeah it was like in the lego box but i
only had like a few pieces yeah exactly
bionicles though
don't get me started really i watched
all three movies oh my god how did you
know there were movies there's they're
actually like great
oh this is from italy by my eve
yeah yeah absolutely absolutely
absolutely let's see where this ball is
reliving my childhood so it comes
through oh my god down the chute down
the slide loaded into this little area
hit this slide again wow nearly kills
these these lego dudes here
i love the exclamation point that's so
good
it reminds me of uh into the
spider-verse when they throw the bagel
and it just says bagel oh yeah yeah
does it hit the head or something like
that yeah i love the
intricacy of this render i think it's
really nice shout outs from italy it's
looking really good i like your colors
too yeah yeah they did a great job
having it be complex but still readable
exactly
very nice great job
all right we got japan
yasutaka
oh my god
[Music]
holy [ __ ]
can i swear on this it's probably chill
yeah
that's amazing
very different
not your everyday contraption wow
freaking beautiful that's incredible
wow great job i don't even know what to
say the style is amazing the lighting is
amazing the tech is amazing look at the
cloth sim
yeah you think that's marvelous designer
could be yeah i need to mess with that
it's amazing oh you've used it yeah i
haven't figured out how to get into
blender yet but uh okay okay but it's
like real-time clothing it's like
amberjam buffer cloth it's amazing oh
nice yeah
i love the colors here
um
absolutely absolutely beautiful the
cyber fans are sick
the lighting is fantastic the lighting
is really nice like the under lit like
golden glow you know what
yeah dude yeah
it's so cool yeah
wow the way the blue complements the red
is really nice the animation is really
good too how the [ __ ] did they do sorry
how the hell did they do that
the little like rip of the guy it looks
like a wireframe or like a spline oh
some sort of is it though
like that doesn't look like geometry it
doesn't it must be splines it looks hand
done yeah
dude it's so good wow it's so intricate
they have a little particle system going
on
yeah that's nuts
so super cool super super cool uh yes
taka
congrats from japan shout outs very sick
very sick
all right who we got we got uh let's see
who's next who's next
the netherlands rick scovers all the way
over
scrovers
oh man
love the sound design on this one
and just the idea that like
the timing is perfect
because they had to get the ball
they had to start the ball at a certain
point and they had to get the ball out
at a certain point in order for all the
renders to like blend together because
next next weekend
all of these will be put together in the
montage with like the music and
everything
so they need to blend together oh
absolutely and it's just like i find it
really cool that
the timing on this is absolutely perfect
that this machine
it continuously works
and it and it follows the rules again
it took a lot of trial and error with
physics sims together right yeah and i
love this like soft
cartoony kind of look
yeah the style of the foliage is really
nice it's very simple
yeah really cool sound design shout outs
from the netherlands rick good stuff
very good stuff
all right this next one's crazy
oh boy let me see let me check the chat
here see if we missed anything no we're
doing good oh yeah it is gonna be hard
to pick a winner so the winners are
already chosen um
i can talk about
why they won
when i announced them at the end once we
get through all 100 i'll let you all
know
are you taking a piece of bernanke
i'm gonna take this as an opportunity to
do the same yeah
oh my god
what the hell i'm quitting 3d
does this one get the light
no
[Music]
freaking crazy
um from
germany leonard
amazing
good god absolutely amazing
that's messed up dude it is messed up
let's track
let's track the machine
so you have the ball
wow basically coming in
on the on the right it gets sliced open
in half it falls down and it falls into
like
this this line oh my god i feel like
physics sims going on and stuff yeah so
it falls into this line right here
and then from there if you notice yeah
it gets it gets slid down this little
chute right here
and gets lined up
to be pushed through
oh i just realized
this other half right here yeah goes
down this way yeah so they get
chips
back there back here dude who knows man
who knows
so they get fused whoa that lighting and
dropped into this tank this water tank
here
and then i guess the water tank oh my
god look at the way wow that particle
sim looks so nice i know
shh that's like a full is that a full
fluid it looks like it looks incredible
but look at the way it lights up this
like wow this like uh chamber yeah and
i'm assuming the balls go
all the way into the back
and they come along this line here
and get dropped into this thing oh my
god this is beautiful yeah
pretty
pretty insane
just everything blends together so well
it's very clear
yet detailed the lighting is gorgeous
yeah there's always stuff to look at
vj shout outs vj hell yeah um good stuff
man we saw you on the last stream uh
very appreciative of uh of all your
support man really cool all looks
amazing so many creative talents there
are so many creative talents and it's
not just limited to these 100 um
nearly 2 000 are y'all submitted so
the all renders montage will come out on
the 28th and that is four hours worth of
all this good god i know it's
messed up it's messed up dude it's not
cool
yeah that's
i don't know about that
no i'm just kidding that's so cool
all right um
oh
oh my god
fairy chill wow i want to live in that
world oh look at those little guys
there's buds down yeah there are buds
down there
the moon like it comes down here yes
that's amazing look at those little
champs there's champ oh there's champs
in there the eye is tracking the ball
there's little buds in there cute
little chips
so how difficult is that to do in
blender damn how difficult yeah can you
get those like pupils following
yeah you like uh you have an empty and
then on the eyes you have bones and on
the bones you put a constraint that's
like track two and then they'll just
like follow the thing okay nice yeah so
this is from christopher from norway
really cool stuff yeah great job chris
lighten up the night
with them mushrooms and then there's
like a little there's a little cavern
back in there
super cool i want to go explore this i
know it's super cool
i love it good stuff christopher from
norway good times excellent all right we
got philippines
up next whoa
nathaniel
damn
that's so cool race
it reminds me of what's that dance style
where it's like this it's like
yeah it's like the uh
so you think you can dance uh
style
is that a thing i just remember watching
that show with my family and like
everybody on that show was like
doing that basically that's what that's
what this reminds me of
that's super sweet yeah super cool
wow i don't know what it is like a
particle accelerator or something but
yeah i don't know i'm having a good time
watching it though yeah it's pretty darn
sweet
wow
tutting it's called tutting oh
my friend devon does a little bit of
that oh yeah yeah gotta get him over
here oh absolutely
all right moving on moving on oh man i
can tell if you don't like this one
let's see from russia dennis
um
for me
the thing that does it that does it for
me
is the little finger move
there's a finger move yeah
that puts it over the edge for me oh my
god that's so nice
very subtle sound design great
composition yeah
you got the incense pots yeah you got
your atmosphere wow really nice uh
contrast with like the gold and green
feels like something out of uncharted or
something 100
yeah that's really nice 100
um shout outs dennis from russia good
stuff congrats on top 100 congrats to
every one of these artists top 100
absolutely yeah
and if you all don't see yourself up in
here no worries congrats on completing
the challenge and getting into like
you know even the all renders montage
it's super cool couldn't do this without
all y'all it's a lot of work it's a ton
of work yeah
to be fair
it's so much work i haven't even
finished mine yet
that's how much work it is
son champ
it's okay slugger cheers
thanks dude
it's a lot of work running these
contests dude like all this stuff oh my
god just the logistics of it sound
insane
yeah there's a lot of like behind the
scenes stuff yeah
all right we got another russian render
krill
kirill ki real
what do we got
another carnival style
[Laughter]
it's a popcorn machine oh my god so he
super heats the ball
pops the god that's amazing and it's
like my job is done here
see ya
peace god one more time
dude that is that super heats that thing
so quick i need to hear that
oh
that sound design is incredible
god that's i i really like that one yeah
shout outs from russia good stuff
popcorn machine i wish it was this easy
oh it's a bag look
oh it's a bag
oh my god yeah brilliant super cool you
got to send this to like any movie
theater chain because they all have like
shitty cgi animations of popcorn from
like
15 years ago yeah so just like email
this to all of them
like maybe 500 bucks to use this at your
movie theater key real you should do it
you should absolutely do that that's
amazing um we got some super chats cody
ward thank you he's loving it um
and raghuvanch
i think we just watched ragamunches
right now really just tune into the
stream after dinner love the content
you'll make by the way there's still one
little easter egg you didn't notice yet
shoot
i'll go back to it
where's roger
one little easter egg we didn't notice
yet
corridor logo we got what does that say
ness
bowser what jackpot oh jackpot okay
there's a one two three on the left some
corridor logos
is there something up top
on the bottom
i mean there's the whole crew there
i gotta apologize for my coffee breath
i have not i can't i don't smell it i
haven't even brushed my teeth yet i have
corners so i can't smell anything oh
yeah
that's chill dude
that's the chillest thing you possibly
could have said just dropped out on you
i don't know what this easter egg is
well what does it say on there
1 000 points
bonus okay
i don't know i mean there's the crew bro
yeah there's the logos
who is that is that nick
yeah
moving on moving on
ragaman good way to get that extra
screen time dude that is solid
good move
all right where are we at where we at
here we are russia it's a russian
kind of kind of day here because it's
our third russian render from sergey
let's see what you got
oh man did you ever read those eye spy
books as a kid i don't know god they
were amazing they're like these things
oh no
[ __ ]
god dang it see this is why i bought a
capture card you know
hold on now hold on now because the
render still works does it yeah the
render still works oh great okay we're
actually just really good ventriloquist
you know yeah we've been practicing for
so long don't do this
let me god
why
um
my camera
wait clint plus peter2.jpg is that a
jpeg just chilling there no no no that's
our overlays oh i see
just a good old time just some buds dude
just some freaking skips
um
let's see
just a blast
having a blast there we go we're back
we're back in it um let's get back to it
y'all
but yeah the the i spy books were like
these beautiful picture books with these
like very particularly placed objects
like this kind of vibe okay little toys
and things you know to like find things
within the page it was really fun oh
what you mean like highlights
you remember that magazine highlights
and it was like it was like a coloring
book
but it was like a very
or not ornate like
it was just packed with detail and you
had to find all these shapes hidden
shapes
it must have been a similar concept but
anyways this reminds me of one of those
books and it's bringing back some great
childhood memories yeah it's like i love
again it's tangible i can touch it you
know um it feels like it's actually
built i love these little slides yeah
they're made really well i love the uh
the wood sounds the rolling on the wood
yeah wow even they got the um the side
of a wood plank perfectly like the
layers of wood stamped into each other
yeah and even these pegs too
to hold them down wow
really cool that's fantastic sergey from
russia good stuff yeah great job very
good stuff
south africa pascal nice
oh my god
wow
oh good jesus christ
that's a golden one
i love that sound design
yeah like the telephone
line
so good how do you do that
dude the sim on that the sim is
ridiculous do you think that's like
houdini or i don't know it's in the
notes like it's in the like
yeah i'd have to pull up the thing a
little bit
yeah super good like that's some of the
best wow look at this right here boom
stretch and snap it's like pulling
pulling and then snaps
dude i remember doing some webs for the
spiderman short film and they are hard
so
kudos to this guy for pulling it off so
well dude they look so good though those
webs i was i was like i remember when
you were playing that at corridor you're
sitting next to me and i looked i was
like
is that cg dude
i remember that moment that made me so
happy yeah
like i
i got super intimidated in that moment
you're kidding i'm not for real but like
i was like i was just like
dang
dang it's very sweet
wow yeah great job
um
south africa pascal good stuff we got
another south africa shock here
we got sound design on it too
whoa
[Music]
oh it's trapped there
wait what dude look on the wall there's
like it's like crossing off the days
oh snap
wow
so what's that design this guy who does
these designs and they like walk on the
beach you seen those oh yeah i i was
more thinking of uh
sid's toys from toy story i see it yeah
i see it
wait so is this guy trapped here oh it's
that dude okay and he's like a machinist
and he's and he's running the machine or
it whatever this thing is
yeah we got some notes up here
trying to escape trying to get out
he's like trapped but honestly he's he's
made it a nice space he's made it very
homey absolutely like the bookshelf and
everything absolutely
so it's really cool like i love tracking
these balls here yeah it knocks that it
goes down like everything has a purpose
here it's really cool
super sick
very good stuff yeah shakir from south
africa very good stuff
nice we got 3 300 people in the freaking
live stream right now son oh my goodness
hell yeah
hmm this one's nice
this one's very nice sounds very nice
this is from rocky wow
from the old u.s of a
making a coffee machine that is
beautiful
it looks perfect
the machine has purpose
it's super cool
it's packed with detail work is
incredible like those mugs the way like
the gradient on those mugs and the way
the paint is kind of tripped off towards
the top it looks so realistic yeah
and light so it hits the light switch oh
my god that's brilliant it sets the
coffee off boom it passes over the water
so it gets the steaming water going
it drops in it turns this wheel here
boom turns that wheel
right and then
coffee beans drop
and boom
that's amazing good stuff yeah very good
stuff looks super good the lighting's
really nice that espresso machine wow
yeah
surface imperfections gorgeous right up
in there good stuff
very good stuff
rocky from the old u.s of a hell yeah
good times great job
all right all right all right
yep
taiwan
you wren
oh my god
very peaceful damn that tune shading
yeah i love it hell because it's like
okay it's tune shading but there's also
like realistic light happening here
like there's light bouncing off and
things like that that's the best combo
for me yeah it looks so cool i love it
that's incredible yeah it's kind of like
uh
yeah but it's less realistic light it's
um i was gonna say like uh
klaus
oh right right right yeah yeah yeah
yeah that's incredible yeah good stuff
you right now i'm curious how they did
that take a closer look
i'm pretty sure this is a blender so you
get the cat going drops down to the
wheel
yeah that's blender you've seen that
tutorial right yeah yeah
but hey if if you want to uh damn me on
instagram and let me know how you did
that lighting i'm very curious heck yeah
and that is your instagram by peter
frankenstein
yeah shout outs
by the way for anyone wanting to follow
peter um he's an amazing blender artist
thank you man he's he's a champ
at heart he's a he's a real champ at
heart real slugger yep um
i got peter's stuff all up in the
description um you got his youtube you
got his patreon you have a patreon i do
have a patreon yeah dishing out like a
bunch of cool stuff a lot of 3d scans a
lot of fun stuff little blender files i
got an egg generator i just put up i saw
that yeah you can generate like
procedural eggs
it's uh yeah it's fun super cool like
you mean like like like like hard-boiled
egg or like like like like a like you're
frying an egg yeah it has like a bubble
slider it has like you can have it be
cooked or uncooked add some pepper on
there
that's really nice um yeah i also just
put up a youtube video today about
making virtual uh stunts in unreal which
is pretty fun so feel free to check out
my youtube yes dude i'm doing some
unreal stuff later this year i'm very
excited very excited i'm excited to see
it i'm excited to watch your video
thanks god damn it
what oh my goodness why
we're just
why
see this is why just leave it just leave
it
that's the thumbnail dude that's the
freaking jump now
it's like
it's like if you get i think it's the
coffee honestly
because you get the jittery feet and you
start stomping
and it jostles the janky usb
like um
like what is it called oh you're kidding
the the wire my my capture card is a usb
freaking dongle and it's janky as all
get out
so just watch them toes okay all right
all right
watch them toes
i bounce my legs so much that's gonna be
tough you have any like zip ties zip
ties
um
so y'all can't be a stream without some
technical div there needs to be a
technical difficulty counter which is a
lean into it yeah yeah so erase the
drink
all right moving on
uh you the uk we got jack from the uk
popping off let's see what you got
and also see if we missed any super
chats i think we're doing great
excellent
[Music]
love that sim oh my god
put it in the wash
i love how chaotic this one is that's
amazing
boosh
that's so good yeah
wow that's really cool yeah it's a nice
little uh nice little touch on it that's
really nice yeah so it drops into the
chute
blasts that through the paper drops into
the cup
washes it time to get washed i love the
jitter on it the shake
yeah the surface imperfections and like
all the good stuff your wall in the back
is all jacked up your lighting is cool
yeah i love the um
it's not like one consistent material
slapped on like
across the surface of the plane there's
like uh inconsistencies like that little
part of the wall chipping away adds some
nice variety to it it's great yeah
super cool yeah great stuff good stuff
jack
all right we got tom from the uk
hook a duck
toy story vibes man yeah oh my god
that's amazing i love the color yeah
great color palette the render quality
is really nice
it's also a great reveal of that title
it's like hook uh duck
the sound design is hilarious
great job yeah the color contrast is
solid in the design back here with the
water
yeah that must have been hand done
and like look at the uh
the little like rope sim they got going
um
right up in here it looks really nice
yeah i guess that whole thing is a
physics soon
yeah that's amazing and then hand
animated from here the droplets hand
animated
yeah not bad looks like it yeah not bad
at all that's fantastic
um
arjun
sodhev shout outs for the super chat he
says for the next challenge like this
check out the zoom pull out sequence in
the music video for apple
by roycstop i think i've seen that a
long time ago i'm a big breakup fan
um check it out love the streams good to
see you peter as well hell yeah good to
see you too
heck yeah
all right all right let's move on here
we got uh
from the us dominic
what you got
really unique oh my god really unique
design that's incredible
super cool wow
so satisfying to watch yep
goodness
it's like those uh
you know those puzzles
where you have to like move the thing to
try and get it into the right
position absolutely it reminds me of the
super version of that
god this is wonderful such a cool idea
you know this would make a great game
this whole concept like a little puzzle
game on the iphone it's like the marble
starts at the top and you gotta get it
to the bottom yes yeah i i thought about
that i was like this would be really
cool as an interactive experience
absolutely whatever that would be
dude if you did like an unreal challenge
you're going to make it level
crazy
then you just make a game together
everyone makes a little
nuts that'd be super cool yeah
god i love this one are those little
allen keys what's going on there oh
waits oh owner weights
so cool wow great job yeah dominic good
stuff from texas
sick excellent
all right
we got vincent
from the uk
chroma nuts
oh my god
these are all so good this is messed up
i'm gonna turn this one off and then
turn it back on okay sounds good all
right
dude look at look at look at the way the
track like this track
jiggles unless wait unless that's like
heat it's heating it up
oh yeah
or cooling it or something oh it's a
snack
it's a little snack pack
it's a crunchy snack and then it gets
hit with like bolts i think it's for
robots
or something wow yeah it's like getting
lubed up in the beginning
yeah so it gets the chocolate the
chocolate runs
and it goes through here gets hit with
the bolts
popped
that's sick that's amazing dude five
cents
five cents that's not bad
you know back in my day these were worth
a cent dude yeah inflation is no joke
totally dude my mom would tell me how it
should she would go to the store and her
parents would give her like five cents
and she could get like five different
candies or whatever mm-hmm wild
good this is amazing yeah vincent solid
jackson from the u.s
wow
oh my god
what movie does this remind you of
i mean blade runner a little bit okay
yes i i know that's not what you're
talking about
um
i don't know shoot what's the name of
that rouge or something i've never seen
that one
um
shoot no it's the um
korean movie
what's it about
it's about a family who like
sleuths their way in
a parasite parasite remember that yeah
in parasite
yeah it does look very inspired by that
so cool i love like the little person in
here i'm sure that's the artist yeah i'm
sure that's your boy jackson
delhi like indiana looks really nice
yeah
in the little truck
so cool
yeah
i love the lighting and the vibes
there's even some uh lights going past
of other cars driving by that we can't
see
that yeah i got that feeling
i think that might just be the hdri oh
but it does look like every time i watch
it i get that feeling
this is very nice
yeah
yeah super cool
all right next up we got peter
from
the us of a this is not me this is not
peter
but it is peter
dude
oh no
oh wow pretty sweet
yeah so this is the first one where the
entire contraption just falls apart
that's hilarious
and somehow the ball still manages to
get to where it's trying to go i love
the chaos yeah it's really cool i love
tracking these so it pops the ball on
the right up
hits the pencil
knocks the dominoes
now what
okay so the dominant this was meant to
happen no way actually it wasn't
it wasn't meant to happen
because you see how the domino falls it
starts this chain
but it hits this leg supposed to go
around there yeah
boom dude that's hilarious so it clips
the light bulb
and the light bulb knocks the like straw
thing
or the crayons
the whole thing falls and the ball is
still top
center going right it falls behind the
whole thing
and manages to fall down here wow
intricate
and you have the rope sim too look at
look at this rope
super good that's wonderful yeah i love
because there have been a lot of rube
goldberg machines but they're very like
excellently crafted ones and it's nice
seeing like a homemade rube goldberg
where it's just like whatever you have
lying around yeah i love that vibe also
i just noticed a fire starts at the end
that's great not good not good
uh jackson roberts
um jackson roberts from the last one did
you guys notice uh the cat in the group
the cat and the graffiti
there's a cat
oh right here
oh
and the graffiti
what is that
or over there maybe that looks like a
bunch of postcards oh yeah maybe it's
not done
corridor what does that say
rodeo video
punisher i i see it's hard to see
it is hard to see what does it say
i yeah what does it say
who knows who knows i'll keep an eye on
it yeah yeah all right next up we got
brendan
from the us of a
oh
hell yeah we got a blender render in
there
sam all right
that's a great idea for render and the
andre labrov uh
fireflies do you ever watch that guy's
channel oh he's so good man he's one of
my favorites
the sound design wow
going across the keyboard i love it so
it goes into the computer
that's hilarious
vapper evaporates it's turned into the
render and comes out oh my god it's
literally that is the render yeah
that's messed up dude yeah that's so
good
it's crazy
goodness yeah it comes right out
and goes across i love the lighting here
studio lighting is really good oh my god
they have the sound baffling panels
yeah oh this is fantastic brendan good
work yeah super cool excellent
evan from florida
wow
very simple beautiful
nice
design
feels like i can touch it feels like it
works
and i love that tail flip again
excellent i love that it feels like
something that could exist in the real
world yeah
just solid render quality good job on
your design good job on the lighting uh
it's a fun little slide yeah
super cool i love the design of the
dragon great stuff yeah evan good work
very good work oh
yeah florida we got kenny
big pokemon fan oh hell yeah
oh that's wonderful i can't get enough
i'm such a sucker for pokemon oh me too
man i miss those games
i got to get a ds ah that's the best
sound design is fantastic
wait who's this on the video screen is
that um
i don't know the new ones oh on the
right there yeah is that must be him
either him or like the creator of
pokemon or something oh i'm not really
sure
ah so sick
yeah this is wonderful it looks like a
master ball or no that's a ultra ball
pokeball
is that a master ball uh yes
yeah freaking love pokemon which ones
did you play i played diamond pearl and
platinum dude diamond and pearl um
on the i think they redid them on the
3ds oh really i think so it was like 3d
it was like 2.5
it was like
similar in the style of like sapphire
and ruby or like heart gold soul silver
um
yeah it's just like that 8-bit like or
16-bit style you love top-down but like
when they redid it they make it like 3d
for the 3ds or it was just like a
remaster it was 3d for the 3ds lightly
updated the graphics and everything
really nice yeah awesome um joshua
yeah thanks uh joshua shout outs um
thank you so much
this is great lovely channel all of uh
you really shine a light on that artist
art history of vfx i want to participate
but both my main hard drives
and my backup fried when i was like 95
done no that's rough dude
rip
dang wait so you lost that data that
sucks so hard and the backup drive
rough that sucks man
dude my
the hearts
they go out to you
thanks for the super chat thanks for the
support joshua rock on
i hope um i hope it didn't get you two
down i hope that uh seeing these top 100
really make you
keep working on your
3d because that's brutal
i've been there i've certainly been
there yeah damn i gotta back up my stuff
me
too
i'm gonna hold you accountable you hold
me accountable okay i'm gonna do it
tonight by the end of this year oh but
tonight's here
it's gonna be gone by then
he said by tonight i said by the end of
the year
all right
next up we got alex from the us
here we go
good god
oh my god
that is fantastic
the animation is
so top-notch
wow look at the way that thing moves so
much personality i know
it's not janky in any way no
that's fantastic
and the slime sim
at the end
yeah dude and the particles up in here
it's
amazing
incredible
so both technically and creatively
that's i gotta ask
is this guy is this a bud
or is this like
i don't know that
i think i feel like everyone's a bud i
mean for sure bud yeah but the word that
comes to mind like right when you
started saying that i was like slugger
it's a slugger yeah okay like definitely
a slugger maybe because slugger has the
word slug in it and it's kind of slug
like it's a little slimy you know
bringing slugger
such a good design you think they
modeled that
i would hope so yeah i'd imagine super
cool yeah alex from the us
amazing great stuff yeah look it hits
the roof
and it knocks like
pieces down the detail it's so good
and it's dark and dim and you're
definitely like pan's labyrinth under
the tree you know yeah wow freaking
gross amazing great stuff yeah
all right we got from switzerland
alexander
wow lovely
beautiful i want to live there
i want to sit on those rocks i know
really i want to watch that waterfall
it's like a perfect mix of nature and
uh
like
infrastructure because you have these
like
cogs and wheels and the design of those
cogs are fantastic yeah
really cool looking nice little slide
and like nice little water you got some
fishies down in there and stuff oh
there's fishies yeah there's little
fishies
there's a little champ right here
yeah super cool very nice
depth there alexander
fantastic yeah good lighting good design
foliage
yeah hot
um we got super chat
arjun uh next challenge as a bass
meditating character on a platform
camera zooms out through the third eye
into different scenes oh snap seem could
be psychedelic interdimensional fractal
could be sweet pretty sweet
have you seen baraka
no
but i
have heard of it it is good watch the
best thing ever it's basically a tour of
the world it's a documentary it's about
two hours long
and it's a tour of the world without any
dialogue it's just music wow and this
the director his name is ron frick he
created this uh basically um
time lapse camera rig that allowed him
to get these insane time lapses of the
stars rotating as he comes underneath
like the arches national park arch you
know and he's just getting these insane
the sun coming up and like clouds
passing by different layers of
thunderstorms
oh so beautiful
what's it called it's called baraka
baraka okay
i've seen it like eight times it is so
good but there's a moment where
it dollies into the back of a dude's
head yeah and it cuts like his cuts are
off the charts
his match cuts dude oh yeah oh so okay
back to the head and then what does the
cutscene it like goes in i think that
they end the movie on that shot so it's
like all in your head kind of a thing
like uh
yeah it's beautiful it's beautiful
um we got some more super chats fred um
shout outs um you learned so much just
from watching you guys killing that
corridor yeah what you guys do so
important for the vx cgi scene in
general love in the rented challenge
olaf from brazil thank you fred much
appreciated
yeah super cool and matt thank you thank
you sir uh watching render challenge is
my new adult saturday morning
that was what i wanted that's what i was
going for was like saturday morning
vibes hell yeah dude that's great
congrats
all right matt we're getting back into
it
all right we got john from the us
what you got
oh yeah
oh wow
that's so satisfying that is so
satisfying
so it hits the cogs goes down the chute
i love the foreground like you can come
out of the box
right and it comes into this yeah i
haven't seen much of that super really
cool
gets into here melts it down into the
foundry
and then
yeah i love them that's so satisfying
it's like
shaving down a uh an acorn into the
perfect sphere
that's
wonderful that's shiny after it comes
out mm-hmm that's great
yeah
lit from underneath there
really cool clever john good stuff yeah
great stuff love the detail in the
background
yeah very nice back here
sick excellent good stuff
all right uh john from the us or no josh
apologies we got josh
oh man
beautiful i don't even know what to say
great sound design
um
i love it it's like refining a a rare
material
it's breaking it down it's chipping away
it's those little hammers are so
satisfying boom yeah the sparks and then
it's like close-up shiny gem
that's a brilliant composition idea to
have that magnifying glass in there
yeah cause it gets it gets you close up
on
on the subject and also
um the idea that this is a perfect loop
so when a new gem goes in it drops
[Music]
a new one and so like the new one would
fall in and it's just this infinite loop
of mining oh look at the wheel in the
back and the cogs in the back and stuff
so good it's fantastic yeah i always
appreciate when like
you know
virtual renditions of machines feel like
they could actually function in real
life it's hard to do
it's super hard to do
yes that's what i really loved about
iron man 1 is that all of the machines
in that felt so tactile and real and
like possible and then like you know i
love the other movies but they kind of
went more into fantasy territory iron
man one was like one of the best iron
mans for sure
yeah it was um
john was it john favreau
good great director
yeah shout outs josh good stuff
excellent
brock from the u.s
um
great uh architectural design
yep
it's very simple
we hadn't really seen any of these
simple designs yet
but i'm a big fan yeah great contrast
and shapes
absolutely very evenly lit
it's like a really fancy
pool
room
what would you call this like
architectural style i don't know but
it's such a style
yeah yeah also fantastic shade of pink
yep
it's so soft and creamy
i love it
so is this the shower i would assume uh
okay okay it's like a bath house kind of
thing yeah what's that place you go to
we spawn spa
the other day it's so good oh it's back
open yeah real nice
yeah we suppose the best oh yeah good
stuff brock yeah very nice i love the
clean simple feeling everything is
very aesthetically pleasing lovely color
palette yeah
um patrick thank you for the super chat
greetings from norway you're the best
love the stuff
thank you sir
amazing i'm glad you're enjoying your
time we got another render from nico in
the us
oh wait hold on
[Music]
this dude's life oh yeah
oh my god that's incredible
so like
i'm guessing okay you have these balls
dropped through this pipe
and there's these like
rough cannonball looking ones
and these ones are no good he's seeing
if it's good [ __ ] yeah
cause like it's funny too because part
of the rules was you have to have a
perfectly reflective chrome ball
and anything with like
any roughness like this
because technically it wouldn't match to
the next render yeah you know what i
mean totally so they all need to be able
to work together and then leave as grown
yes that's hilarious so he's totally a
friend report him yes
[Laughter]
anti-union workplace art
totally a 1984 vibes yeah god the
character model and the animation
so much personality
yeah i feel like this dude's name
actually is bud
i want to watch a whole short film about
this guy yeah
yeah no the the
the animation is really good
that's fantastic
oh yeah look at the sway on the chute as
it as the ball comes out yep
that's wonderful connected to the pipes
and everything
it feels kind of like
the way
stop-motion characters are animated like
clay claymation
yeah like um
what is it not two frames a second like
12 frames a second or something
it does feel about the way he's moving
mm-hmm
now he's definitely moving once every
frame
yeah
just like the style in which his limbs
are moving feels reminiscent of
yes
and also like the way
he looks like he feels like that head is
made of clay
it looks so good yeah that's crazy geez
great job
shout outs uh nico from the u.s
nicholas shepherd
uh you two are rad cheers you legends oh
yeah cheers
champ we got us we got a champ in the
chat nicholas shepard
super champ with the super chat
my name is bud and this is my story
that's great
oh man
okay what else we got um alec from the
us
hit us with it
that's what i'm talking about
that's what i'm talking about
that's really nice it's just fun to
track
like where it goes
it's a
i'm having trouble like
describing this to myself in my head but
like it's it's like visually simple yet
very complex super complex it's so clear
yet there's so much going on yeah so
from here the ball drops in
and it hits this u
and like you gotta follow one at a time
there's a switcher so they have a
switcher it's so mechanically accurate
because you see the second one that
falls in right here wow
yeah so it
one ball hits another ball hits but goes
a different direction
so there's multiple things happening at
once right
and you actually look here
so you see on the bottom right this
little spherical
um like cylinder that it's falling into
the funnel yeah
right so they're going into that
wonderful
and then they're dropping down and
there's like so much going on it goes up
the chute
and if you look at this like cross
section in front there's actually two
balls pre-loaded you see how this one
falls in right at the bottom
it falls in right there to make an even
platform for this ball to come across
and that all three wow
drop down and reload
that's wonderful it's so like how did
you come up with this alec it's amazing
honestly that's messed up
oh we got what's up casey we got casey
popping off right now
what's going on hotness
hotness yo
i think
i think it's a champ's birthday today
you're kidding it's casey's birthday
today wow
can we sing happy birthday we have to
sing happy birthday will we get
demonetized for that
i they recently um took away the
copyright for it i believe really i i
heard that yeah all right are you ready
to sing happy birthday to casey i got to
warm up these pipes
all right here we go all right
three three two one happy birthday to
you
happy birthday to you
happy birthday dear kcc edwards
happy birthday to
you
turning uh 46 this year i believe
cheers mm-hmm looking great for 46.
looking great for 46. not a single
gray hair
on in his nostril in his in his nostrils
you've looked up there i've seen i've
gotten pretty up and close wow
demonetized
casey is an insanely talented composer
if you like orchestral music you should
check him out on spotify and uh as the
soundtrack for my spider-man short film
yeah casey's the best fantastic it was
really fun working with casey for that
he is my go-to composer the number one
the champ the slugger
the scout he's he's all of it and uh oh
he's turning 69. oh i see he's here i
started that wrong wow he's looking
great through 69. he is looking great
for 16. fantastic um
but yeah i know casey's amazing he did
like the floors lava he did um which is
one of my favorite short films ever
so much fun thank you when brett is like
what does he say he's like
hip hip he's like
yeah no he's he's like he's like he's
like yeah he's like hip hip because he's
trying to get us all riled up he's like
hip hip hooray hip hip roommate's
throwing through room is trying true i
was like and he like he's like no let's
do this hip hip and he just slips dude
and just
no he fully he jumps for you yeah
that's
it cracks me turns out i freaking skill
it dude it's so funny straight into the
skillet uh so good yeah but yeah casey
happy birthday i'll see you later man
uh good stuff alec
steven now leave these lights on
for this one
oh my god
this one's so good i think i'm done
being human
i want to be one of these frogs chilling
in this place look at this little guy
that's amazing oh there's so many little
champs
i think there's a sleepy frog in here
you're kidding i think
that's my spirit animal um
where's the sleep no i lied there's no
sleepy frog
this is another render i'm thinking of
god
look at the color dude
and it's so intricate look at the
details you should be ashamed of
yourself i am no i'm talking to the
person who made this oh
yeah what are you doing with yourself
no this is incredible
um steven yeah steven amazing the color
the lighting the design the characters
the contraption like firing on all
cylinders here
yeah i was telling clint earlier it
reminds me of uh the vr game gnomes and
goblins by john vavroa and lucasfilm if
you guys
haven't played that and you have a vr
headset definitely do it it's very
reminiscent of this and vice versa he
made a game jon favreau made a game yeah
it's more of like a cinematic experience
cool um but it's really fun it's like an
hour long it's a little bit overpriced
but uh it's a great experience it's a
good time yeah
check out these these like crystals
there's these crystals back here and
they're like emanating these like
particles and stuff that's wonderful
and i love how this is all for just this
guy to go to the next level
like i didn't even realize he's just
trying to elevate
aren't we all
mm-hmm
absolutely beautiful stephen so good
so so bad that's hilarious i love how
his neck goes like that when he
does he's like
that's great
that's great
um i think do we miss a little super
chat action up in here or are we
chilling
um joshua joshua joshua i see you thanks
for the level oh thanks for the love
oh yeah this is the man who lost
everything yeah literally lost
everything vaulty evga psu killed three
hsds and ram back at it learning soft
body tearing in houdini sorry for the
double chats
sorry for the double chest dude you're
you are
helping it helping us out helping two
buds out here so we really appreciate
you uh want to let people know get a
wireless cloud backup
okay
okay yeah i think that's the way i'm
gonna do it it's i'm like dropbox or
something it's still on a server
somewhere else yeah but at least it's
somewhere else
right you know
yeah i mean i guess it's like if if
everything burns then you're good mm-hmm
[Music]
or you can just give me a hard drive
with all your stuff on it you'll just
keep it under your bed for safekeeping
under my pillow next my glock
all right logan from
texas yeah
yeah oh that's hilarious i love how
peaceful this one is it's great
that guy's arms going up is so funny
yeah
i love it it's such a great contraption
yeah
wonderful job
i'm just any time i i've realized
anytime i see a fluid sim in any of
these i just like get a little anxious
oh cause you're like like like it better
be good no no no like i
doing fluid sims myself it's like it's
always such a pain yeah and so i'm just
like seriously kudos to everybody who uh
those fluid sims same
in the renders same this one is
fantastic great colors yeah really nice
colors and i love it's like
this is what you got to do as a
lifeguard like lifeguards are watching
this like
checks out
taking notes
it's really good
wait what causes that drain to pop off i
don't
great question this this wheel oh this
wheel
so it's all part of the uh experience
wait no no no no it's toggled
it's toggled nice
that's so good oh yeah
like when everything serves a purpose
that's when i'm like
what look at how this look at how this
starts oh my god
the water that's amazing it comes in and
scoops it and it starts pouring
oh my goodness
and then it pops the kid in the back of
the head it gives him a
near heart attack and i love the crusty
band-aid
that's great
great job
it's great logan
logan's a slugger i was about to say
holy
what a strong visual style
yeah
[Music]
this is so cool
it reminds me of two things yep
first
transformers
i was gonna say it does remind me okay
wait say what you're gonna say and then
i'll say there's no way you can write
you think so the second one it reminds
me of is um
one at the end when you like
get into the boss's layer and you go
down that spiral platform all the way to
the bottom and everything is made out of
this like weird organic
layered patterned metal
it look it looks like this interesting
yeah oh yeah i was just gonna say um
with transform something
really cool i heard about the sound
design
is that you know there's so much going
on with transformers and they're such
complex machines yet they made a point
to make the sound design very simple oh
because it's like in it's michael bay
movie so many things are happening on
screen at a time but they really only
focus on one thing and just leave sound
out for the rest so it's like very easy
to understand and it seems like that's
something they did here too so it's like
reminiscent of transformers in the
visual style and the sound as well which
is cool yeah because if you were to do
audio for literally everything on screen
it would be overwhelming it's too
overwhelming yeah so you want to do
sound design
like when it comes to sound design you
want to accentuate certain moments that
you want the audience to pay attention
to totally so they're definitely doing
that here um and i love the little
trickly
that that's fantastic oh my god
wow how do you think this stuff that's
amazing it's such a crazy style yeah who
would have thought shout outs jerson
yeah great job jefferson
india oh man
ebitda
whoa party mode oh my god that's amazing
the first half looks like your house son
wooden plants yeah
oh that's fantastic party mode man i
love that super cool
yeah the render quality on this is
ridiculous the lighting is awesome up
here i love the smooth sanded wood look
fantastic yeah super cool
dot from india shout outs
that's a golden one wow
is this mr gaming watch
it looks like game and watch
but i think it's actually donkey kong
yeah um i technically don't know game
watch had his own game right i don't
know
from smash i think this is like early
donkey kong
um i love how
just the aesthetic here is incredible
because it feels like you're actually on
the
i don't even know what this console is
it's no idea before my time game boy
no
it's some crazy like
it is a game and watch
it's its own console oh my god
that's so cool
dang i love the mixture of
you know
the realistic style and
it's a 2d 5d
it's so good
incredible yeah so good and the sound
design is great
shout outs yuri from israel great job
beautiful
poland cord
what we got
wow
wait was that a uh
like a roller coaster cam that went off
it looked like it
but i think
it's a teleport device oh i see yeah wow
i love their use of lego style here yeah
incredible and i love how the bottom
half is super colorful
yeah the contrast
really like
if it was just monochrome or just super
colorful it wouldn't have been as
powerful as it is here with the
contrast between the two and i like how
they snuck colors up into the gray part
too yeah
dude these little pieces like the
connector pieces on those gears yeah
back such memories oh man
really man
so sick this is fantastic i love this
like toy teleporter thing it's super
cool those surface imperfections on
those legos yeah the smudges right up in
here you can see them really nicely
ah that's a really fun one yeah it's
super fun this looks like some like sort
of lava bubble pit or like a
i don't know what that is
because it's definitely like a watch out
scenario right you know
that's cool dude and also the color
palette they chose for those legos is
fantastic
yup
it's your classic colors
just classic colors
shout outs cord from poland good stuff
we got alex from taiwan
oh kind of a borderlands type thing
going on yeah
nice
oh that's wonderful so i think this is a
bomb
so you see the c4 it looks like with
like a keypad and stuff and i think it
diffused the bomb
so it's an ied emphasis on the eye
wait why
imp improvised
uh it's very like
oh slap together yeah
i love the style here
so it hits through here knocks these
three balls and it knocks a screwdriver
down
a screwdriver
on the left yeah so yeah it is
screwdriver looks like a screwdriver
yeah and then it's some c4
that's wonderful knocks that down super
cool yeah alex that's great congrats
good stuff we got um
one dead duck from the uk shout out wow
nice steampunk action i love this right
here that's great
great design yeah
super cool wonda duck has been
part of this community watching these
streams doing these challenges since
like the beginning yeah he's a og
old school
um but i love the design
yeah it's really cool steampunky you got
this theme coming in here probably
action uh essentials or not accents
yeah this contraption here is really
cool the realism is fantastic
agreed scratches in the window
yeah good stuff yeah fantastic mr one
dead duck shout outs to ya
marlon from the philippines what you got
dude
oh wow
so good oh my god excellent mechanical
design so good
we're gonna watch this one more time
oh my god just using every second every
frame so let's follow this i love the
exponential curve of speed here
so it comes in hits the ramp
goes up into the loading dock
falls into this like carousel thing that
pushes it up and over
and it hits this one little block bunk
falls down
gets into this little back and forth
slope situation
and gets primed
into this little pusher wow which shoves
it right up so satisfying and down yep
like a little loop comes down
hits the spiral
gets triggered pushed by this little
thing it's a little hard to see but it
gets pushed by the thing on the right
flips up
back around and down that's fantastic
it's so good like
how do you design this i don't
know
incredible
i wonder if some of these people are
just like mechanical engineers you know
i wonder
i wonder because i wouldn't know where
to start i mean i imagine there's a lot
of overlap in those fields you know like
cad designers and 3d people yeah i don't
know
good point great stuff though yeah
marlon good stuff uh next up we got k4
animation from poland
[Music]
[Laughter]
that's hilarious yeah the render quality
is incredible the lighting is very nice
everything you did here is great the
sound design is my favorite part sound
design is very good it's why is it so
funny
like what what makes this so funny i i
couldn't even tell you that's a good
question the absurdity of it all i guess
so yeah
like you're watching this from
like if this was you
and you were like close up on that truck
it'd be like oh my god
yeah but the fact that you're just
watching it
wreck wreak wreak havoc
wreck havoc
i think it's weak
it sounds right but what does that even
mean uh
i don't
know or care it wreaks havoc it's
wreaking havoc right now
and it just like
you're just watching this oh my god one
more time with the sound chain event
chain of events here yeah
[Music]
it's the chaos yeah yeah it's the
instant chaos
shout outs that's k4 animation good
stuff
this one was made just for me
are you a charcuterie kind of guy i love
a charcuterie
me too
yeah me too i want to come over for a
shortcut yeah sweet let's do it man
yeah this is great great render quality
rolling off the cheeses good chain of
events
some nice polygon models in there
oh yeah the uh can you how many can you
count well um some of the cheese is
definitely and then those bottles are
from polygon and i believe the grapes
yeah
which is
cheese slide does it kill that mouse
wait there's a mouse now
if it killed no okay the mouse is fine
it's just a button if you killed that
mouse i would
delete it from this timeline it's just a
bud trying to chill
oh he's chilling
he's got some great uh tricep strength
yo brief or dollar ninety nine that's is
that cheap i think that is cheap well
how much brie is it
that's a good question probably per
pound
okay oh then that's a very good deal
cheese brie is my favorite brie for like
a like a goat i'm not a goat cheese fan
no you don't like the tanginess
maybe it's the texture i don't know
it's a little bit chalkier yeah i'm a
fan of uh
extra extra extra sharp cheddar
oh yeah like tillamoo like right to the
bathroom oh yeah
tillamook is the best yeah
oh wait
what is that the godfather
represent i guess dude nice
tiny little wine bottle danny good stuff
hell yeah love that one tyler from the
u.s of a
heli oh my god
very nice wow this whole challenge is
bringing back so many childhood memories
i know there's one uh didn't make top
100 but it's uh the game mousetrap
oh my god they did a full-on one yeah
and just because some of them or most of
them didn't make top 100 doesn't mean
they're not amazing it's tough to pick a
hundred so
god this is fantastic yeah like uh
arcade floor as the wall
yeah
totally like laser tag vibes cool
lighting
i've actually been uh working with that
recently for my vr game really it's like
yeah the uh the opening menu because
it's like takes place inside an arcade
game and the menu is in an arcade and
they have like that floor and everything
nice that's awesome yeah i love seeing
this this is great when are you trying
to get your game finished by bro
i don't know
i have no like scope of reference as to
how long this will take i'm hoping like
the next couple months okay it's going
along it's we're making steady progress
okay so yeah like this year oh
definitely this year so like
same time time frame as like maybe
uploading your files
yeah same like backing up everything
yeah you need to back that stuff up
probably
today
in case yeah i mean if you do i will
okay okay
sweet all right you guys can't see it
but we shook hands
you know it's like my arm is kind of
extra long is it kind of
a little bit we're just a little bit
longer
these days that's nice
thank god check out the uh surface
imperfections on the flap that's really
nice when it opens
um oh it has that like nice graininess
to it yeah like if you scratch your
fingernail over top it's like
that's fantastic good stuff great job
tyler
golden glow golden glow award the golden
glows dude that's your award show the
game glows the golden glow awards
um canada farzad
what do you got
jesus
that's insane
that's amazing
beautiful
ah such a strong style yeah i love it
it reminds me of
ghosts of tsushima
with the foxes you can like chase chase
the foxes oh really go back to their den
and they give you a bunch of stuff oh
that's so cool
ah
beautiful style wow yeah
beautiful fantastic job yeah
dude we still got 3 700 people up in
this chat right amazing that's crazy
thank you all for uh for joining us for
this and for peter for stopping by i'm
having a lot of fun dude this is great
me too uh vijay thank you thank you
thank you for the very generous super
chat oh my god that is very generous
absolutely incredible um glad you're
loving them wondering how the top 10
will look so there will be no top ten
we're just going through and we're going
we're going through every single one all
the way to the to the 100th render and
then at the end we're going to just
announce the three us winners and the
three international winners
um so technically like top six in each
or top three in each category
um it's just easier that way you know
it's a little bit more fun to
really show how cool cool these renders
are as opposed to like ripping on them
why they're not getting leveled up and
all this stuff it's an iterative process
it is yeah yeah live and learn you know
oh yeah
um but farzod good stuff
very good stuff here
moving on dylan
from the u.s
oh
hell yeah
oh my god
i'm such a big portal fan dude there
were so many portal records really there
were there's probably 50 portal renders
so many is the best one
yes
yeah in my opinion in my opinion yeah
wow yeah really cool that's fantastic
beautiful style yeah really match that
visual style well of the game like the
animation on this is crazy the render
quality is crazy
um really utilizing everything from the
game in a really cool way yeah the way
those panels are animated yeah look at
the way they pop out here it's like
perfect so good
and it's very it's very easy to read
that's another thing here like judging
all these choosing the top 100 and
choosing the winners it's like
how easy is it to read the animation of
the ball and like what's happening if
you lose it
you know totally i feel like
it's hard to follow i mean that's the
cardinal sin of filmmaking is to be
confusing
yep mm-hmm
that's fantastic oh look at that little
goop going through those tubes where
look at that
oh yeah super cool that's great dylan
very good stuff great stuff yeah
god wonderful yeah that's amazing
we got uh
tauko toco from finland
i love the lighting
the lighting is my favorite
that's wonderful it's a little b-ball
uh contraption so the basketballs are
coming down and it's it's just shooting
hoops you know
i think it actually made one shot
i think it made one shot
so the beginning
right here oh
did it make that one yeah it looks like
it did because the net that's pretty
that's a swoosh
right there yeah little swoosher
that's great yeah how that marble get in
there this one right here yeah yeah so
dropped in it goes from the top that's
great it falls into this box
and it drops it just basically just
drops down
and then rolls back in that's great i
like this one yeah uh tauco toco
good stuff very good stuff i dig it i
love that lighting yeah fantastic
lighting
i've i i've realized that like
any time i see a photo on instagram
where i'm like wow this is so pretty i'm
like it's bounce lighting yeah it's all
about lighting like every time every
single time there's bounce lighting in a
shot it looks so good do you want to
explain what bounce lighting is yeah
just if you have like a really strong
light hitting a bright surface usually
and the the light uh bounces off that
surface onto the surrounding area looks
really nice for whatever reason
it fills the area and like just fills it
with a soft general lift of light
that's why uh all the unreal five stuff
looks so nice it's because they have a
new
lumen system
i can't wait i can't wait that's so have
you downloaded it yet it's downloaded
but i hadn't had time to dive in it's
really fun yeah it's like dumb how easy
it is to make stuff look good
um next up we have t zion
from us
oh that's wonderful
this is a little play
oh my god the cords
that's wonderful yeah
um i love the style all wood it feels
like it could actually work
this is something in grandma's house oh
for sure yeah like this would definitely
be like we've had this for years and
like this is your grandma's you should
take it now oh wow i wish
that's so sick
i love the idea of having it be the
interior of an instrument
oh my god the interior of an instrument
that's crazy
uh stephen thank you for the super chat
hell yes you noticed the marble knocks
the bb core off and that's why the
others miss
yeah the marble
that damn marble so it knocks it off
course
boop oh it pushes it down
and then they all start
missing uh
clover
that's great
yeah good stuff tz on
hopefully i'm pronouncing these names
right you know can't get them all right
though but
caleb from the us
[Applause]
i'm gonna go ahead and turn this off and
then turn it back on again all right
sounds good yeah
wow
yeah
so much detail
so much
uh
moving parts my goodness so much detail
yet such strong shapes and contrast it's
very readable
that's hard to do
the lighting is solid
you got that warm glow up top super cool
yeah i love the
like monochromatic with splashes of
color it's really nice such a high-tech
vibe yeah
this is great caleb good stuff
excellent very good stuff
we got ben
from australia
[Music]
my goodness oh my god
so check this out
three heads come off hilarious and the
heads drop in and you need all six heads
to like release the ball or something
like that that's amazing yeah have you
ever watched the air conditioning
no but i've seen some crazy it reminds
me of this one clip where eric has a
guest like on the couch and he's like
now it's time for choose a briefcase and
like three beautiful models come out
holding briefcases yeah and the guest is
like uh okay number two and the woman
opens it and pulls out a gun and just
shoots the other two people oh my god
it's ridiculous
but yeah that's what this reminds you of
just that top part yeah that's hilarious
yeah this is a really cool pinball
machine or
slot machine
gambling thing i don't know
yeah but i love how like
these are all heads from the different
people that's super cool so fun
three super chats popping off thank you
all let's start from the top um so yeah
stephen we got you thank you so much
um vfx dump
i'm about to take one of those after
this coffee
same dude same dude
um i forgot to mention when mine came up
john voss you can see
old balls on the bars where the metal
pours the ball has to be melted to get
to the end anyway thank you and cordor
got me into cg hell yeah heck yeah i
just love all of the intricacies of each
one of these renders like y'all put so
much love into every single one of these
um vfx dump shout outs man thank you so
much for the super chat and for the
support and martin i see you as well
loving the challenges and the
submissions good job guys will the next
challenge be announced during the stream
heck no
no
there were
so many challenges like
this like we're gonna we're gonna chill
on the challenges um for a minute i
don't know how long but like if we do
everyone if we do a challenge a big
community challenge like yeah every
month i will probably pass away
yep so i don't want that no no we gotta
we gotta pace ourselves here so we gotta
have time to level up a little bit come
back come back at it strong for the next
one but i do have some very very cool
ideas for the next community challenge
um
yeah we'll announce the next one in in
in a bit in a bit um so let's just you
know keep uh keep learning keep growing
great doing cool stuff sounds good
um
moving on yeah let's go peter you're
gonna love this one yeah i know you're
gonna love it i got my hand on the
button
[Music]
oh my god
that's amazing
wow it's very animation yeah that's
fantastic super unique i had i had to
get this one it's just so unique and so
well done the animation is crazy the
built-in motion blur the color like all
the notes on the back is like it's
incredible dude that with the in the
middle when it goes across and it turns
into just like goop for a while there
yeah yep that's so sweet
wow yeah this punch boom oh my god
smack
dude i want to learn
how to do animation like this
yeah oh my god look at the guy it kills
the guy it kills the guy or it knocks
him out no then he comes out of the wall
oh he is teased oh incredible
that's so cool what's up on the eggs get
the shout out
this is so good
450 450 frames yeah like all the notes
in here so like this is between what
what what's this
hold on now
there we go
um yeah he's got all these notes like
three between frames 335 and 340. what
oh the google chrome
oh my god that's hilarious
just the chrome logo for one frame
that's so goofy i love goofy little
details like that
um there's some flags in there
flags oh like uh country flags yeah
is does this have anything to do with
that subreddit poland ball i have no
idea what that is but i always see it i
have no idea
i love how
i'm assuming yeah uh this guy collins
from australia fantastic job all these
hashtags toxic balls
who knows shiny balls
i think there's like balls for clint
yeah balls for clint on the side like
what the heck
if you guys post anything about the
stream make sure to hashtag balls for
clint uh on your post it's a thing it's
kind of a it's like half a thing yeah
it's a little weird
wait you're kidding it actually is i'm
not okay that's hilarious
um we got more super chats hold on it's
popping off um save polar bears agreed
uh love watching your streams and seeing
all the cool ideas people put together
thank you so much and i love watching
all these too
it's a good time
my god whoa
austin not even the message just the
hype just the hype a pair thing
thank you sir
for the super chat
really cool of you
amazing amazing
all right moving on we got simon from
australia what you
got remarkable
[Music]
whoa
pretty insane i think he was watching tv
it says like i can taste the best in
show or something like that
oh my god
really cool wow
i love the mix of like
uh
15 fps and 30 fps yeah seeing like
traditional animation
uh styles
for like 2d animation being put in 3d is
really nice yeah the squash and stretch
and all that kind of thing yeah
it blows up the kitchen
or when i smoke coming out that's great
yeah
how do they do that smoke that's amazing
it's really good
i don't know it looks really nice it
might be like an asset
animation asset pack or something right
this looks fantastic yeah
simon very very good great job
that's amazing mm-hmm
great animation i love the way the uh
what's it called like the manhole cover
flips up at the end yeah
god dang it
yeah great that's awesome
um jordan from the uk dude i love this
one
wow that's wonderful super solid yep
it reminds me of um
[Music]
shoot what's that guy's name winterstet
winterstadt when like the like
the
the
satisfying uh storage
no no no no no no it's a guy on
instagram who makes these like
satisfying loops that look like this oh
yeah
oh wait we got more super chats oh my
goodness thank you soto we got soto
watching out for y'all oh yeah
let's see what we got
douche canoe
flipping people's canoes i guess huh all
right
love the community challenges these are
these artists are super talented i agree
i can't wait next weekend the
14th today's the 14th the 21st the top
100 montage is coming out you can see
all these
back-to-back and then
the all-range montage on the 28th stay
tuned uh we got froggy
something yeah froggy woo
uh
balls for clay clint all right shout
outs agreed harsh
harsh dodea
uh this is my first super chat and i
would love a life-size pinball machine
video
well whoa there's going to be a
pinball machine um category in the all
renders montage coming out on the 28th
so lots of pinball renders for you to
watch
quarter on your channel always inspires
me to step out and shoot yes that is
awesome
shout out to all thanks for the super
chats
yeah this renders so good i love it it's
so good
i love seeing the
light from the pink surfaces leaking
onto the white ah it's beautiful
so beautiful
gorgeous good stuff
ah
so good
so good god that's incredible i love
this one
the render quality is insane
the materials are so good and this
contraption serves a purpose yeah
wow great color great design
what a diorama i hate style like
the colors yeah and the way the
octopuses uh limbs are constructed
yeah all the different little pieces is
so clever that's hard to do like to get
i don't even know how how would i do
that i guess it'd just be pretty simple
yeah
um but look at this it goes into it it
loads into the cannon and fires boosh
and kills the octopus you see the eyes
they switch oh my god that's two x's
yeah jesus punk
it goes down wow
ah so good in that piece of uh in the
ocean is just a piece of like acrylic
that's being rotated like this
that's so good oh yeah yeah totally
it's very clear very readable
that's fantastic yeah one of my
favorites
super good stuff
wow
pretty darn insane
amazing
matthias from austria
experiment going wrong
that's so cool
yeah wow it's amazing i love how the
scientists like freeze up yeah he freaks
out it like takes off
all right here we go it takes off and
then you see him in the window down
there oh really yeah you see him in the
window down there
yeah right in here and he's like stop
stop stop stop stop
so good that's incredible yeah i gotta
do one of these for that one i love that
i love the story it's telling i love how
chaotic it gets
absolutely looks beautiful too yeah it
does very good stuff amazing
dude i'm gonna crack my uh spicy water
yeah i'll join you on that yeah
ready three two one
cheers
oh
how you doing hey holding in there
i'm hanging in here yeah how are you
hanging in i'm good okay
are we halfway done please
here we go
bangladesh
safiyan
oh no what a shame no what a shame
oh man what a shame that's rough
great render though i love the detail
this is their submission from
the alternate realities challenge
just on a card in blender that's
hilarious
lots of little hidden secrets in here
gets into the computer blue screens it
not good
that's hilarious you know that happened
to me once you're kidding mm-hmm
i had um my
like i had a water cooled situation at
one point and it leaked into my computer
no and i was like no more i don't need
to water cool my freaking computer oh
god i have a water cooler on my computer
you'll be fine it's just sitting on the
top it's like a yeti cooler
get that out of there dude yeah back up
your stuff today i got my spicy water on
hand though
that's hilarious
yeah this is amazing um chaffian this is
great great stuff yeah yeah hilarious
we got leo from brazil up next
that's great
very intricate tiny sound design very
grounded in reality
i like it turns on the light goes
through the pencils in the back
hits the scissors goes down the slope
hits the erasers and we're done
yeah
good stuff leo
dig it
rendered well
very reminiscent of the office the show
yes
yes oh it literally has the mug from the
show oh really yeah it's it's like the
world's best boss
where really stupid something world's
best boss where where are there
it says that it definitely says that it
definitely says
i was just misreading that
that's awesome
heck yeah good stuff leo
we got gallon from canada
oh man
[Applause]
that's amazing i love the sound design
yeah
really cool stuff yeah it's just great
all around really good animation great
lighting the volumetrics are really nice
good times
the canon looks especially nice that
little
sim right there is like an amberjam
thing or something yeah
looks wonderful
good lighting with the um spotlights too
dragging the spotlights
i think that burst is uh composited oh
yeah that's probably how i would do it
um
adam great stuff or not adam adarsh
thank you for the super chat question
what do you think is the perfect way
or order of learning cg and 3d stuff
um i think
getting a basic grasp on your 3d
software you know watching some beginner
tutorials and then once you feel like
you can you kind of have your footing um
just picking projects that last either
like a day or a few days or a week
and just tackling those one at a time
maybe focusing on different aspects of
the software as you go andrew price has
um a lot of great podcast episodes on
that particular question so i recommend
checking those out
yeah um and also just like
follow tutorials that
you naturally would enjoy you know like
do things that you love doing don't
force yourself to do stuff you don't
really like doing yeah at first you're
gonna you might have to do that at some
point like if you're on the guitar
you're gonna have to learn your scales
but like
just have fun with it follow where your
passion is and just go down that as far
as you possibly can yeah
that's like the what's what makes it the
easiest is if you're having fun doing it
then it doesn't feel like work exactly
it's great yeah exactly thanks for the
super chat
oh let's get your let's get your window
let's get you a little bit done i'll
just slide you down just a little bit
i know dude the whole stream is kind of
kind of ruined should we restart yeah we
can restart okay cool let me just
restart your computer real quick okay
you can pour that pour that water all
over it
all right we got a
hang
from canada oh actually austin
super chat thank you
when you're compiling these for the
final animation do you consider how each
one will relate to the next in terms of
order they appear yes i will
certainly
order the top 100 to match as well as
possible together and with the music so
it'll be a full-on uh curated event hell
yeah
you're gonna like this one oh my god
holy [ __ ]
are those furbies what are those they're
furbies dude that's hilarious
super creepy
the render that's incredible i love the
animation of that snake like ungodly
creature yeah super furby
and i i love like the catholic
inspiration yeah it's so funny
it's super creepy it's super out there
and weird it feels like something from
adventure time yeah um and the lighting
and the color is really nice
yeah yeah i love like absurd ideas done
very uh
artfully yep this is very well done
hang from canada i love that that that's
getting a golden glow the golden glow
the golden glow
wonderful oh we got liam one of the mods
from canada shout outs
oh
yeah this one's super cool
it's like a really cool like puzzle key
unlocking thing
that's really nice yeah the sound design
on the glass is so on point it is super
on point yeah
um yeah liam if you're in here visual
um how did you do the sound design for
that glass did you record it yourself um
yeah i wonder
yeah fantastic yeah and
wow like the
the color palette and the background
work is fantastic that wallpaper yeah
super crunchy and like feels like an old
hotel yeah
that's nice i dig it yeah great stuff
good stuff very very good oh it's
literally uh picking a lock
yeah that's hilarious it's like opening
wow
opens it up it reveals the ball that's
amazing yeah
wait what's going on in here
well this person in there oh
oh my god
that poor woman
i didn't even see
oh no
oh no are they are they free now
no
they're just in there that sucks locked
or not i don't know maybe they're
i'm just like taking a nap and having a
good time could be hopefully hopefully
yeah
um evolver interactive
always appreciate you thank you so much
just here to support peter
okay great yeah [ __ ] off yeah dude
heck yeah that's great that's good to
hear um
missed two super chats before that let's
find out let's find out we gotta hit
them all
evolver
william jane how many do we have left
good question the stream might get a
little laggy as i zoom out here
35
something like that
yeah nice dude snuck that one in there
that was good
but it was still laggy um william jane
we got about we're two-thirds through
right now about two-thirds of the way
through
um
and i think we got everything there yeah
we got everything sweet
all right moving on
czech republic daniel
what you got for us
there's a head in there
oh wow
that's great the like bassy sound
effects on the watermelon
they're like thump
there's a head in that freezer dude
minus the head this was my refrigerator
in college
let's not talk about it silent hill
vibes yeah for sure great stuff you had
a silent hill fridge in college you know
i'm not proud of it
it wasn't that
bad daniel that's good stuff yeah that's
fantastic
uh czech republic we got patrick up next
whoa
nice top-down scene very clever idea
yeah there's a couple top-down scenes up
in here this was my favorite one
um and to listo did redmi top 100
we're getting there
oh yeah
we're getting there
i love it fantastic yeah it's really
unique
super clever
just tearing up that house
reminds me of the kill bill fight scene
uh going through and just wrecking so
good wreaking wrecking havoc wreaking
havoc is it wreaking or wrecking havoc
but reeking is not even a word like
reeking is smell bad but wrecking is
like you're wrecking things but when you
spell it out it's w-r-e-a-k
ing
that that's a word i'm not sure about i
don't know i'm pretty sure it's a word
wreaking havoc
i'm like eighty percent sure
oh good times i'll keep an eye on the
child soon okay
ah hey
thaddeus oh
[Music]
from the czech republic oh my god it
makes a little tune little jams
[Music]
heck yeah that's fantastic
peter um it is wreaking havoc by the way
it is wreaking havoc yes i have to
figure out what that word is like what
does that mean um call more everyone
some serious talent here amazing work
agreed thanks to the super chat home
uh i gotta get the door real quick okay
cause i think there's a birthday cake at
the door you're kidding i'm not
for casey no
oh my god everybody say happy birthday
to ken
how's it going y'all how are we doing
how are you feeling today how's how is
everybody
how's everybody's mood um
[Music]
well i'll speak for myself i feel uh i'm
feel i'm having a great time just
chilling with my buddy clint a little
sleepy had a bit of a late night last
night
but uh you know i have about three
coffees in me right now
so i'm feeling great
um feeling a little euphoric i'm feeling
a little blasted
right now uh but you know generally good
and uh yeah i hope you guys are all
doing well i hope everybody
uh enjoys their saturday gets a little
exercise get those endorphins going
you know it's the best thing you can do
would you get oh [ __ ]
this
this is what i needed okay
how do i freaking do this this is what i
this is what i need okay for the stream
that's gonna hopefully stop
the the lagginess
[Laughter]
wasn't available at best buy
amazon had it so wow
i'm just gonna install this real quick
i'm gonna shut down the stream okay cool
all right i got you thanks dude
all right
back at it uh czech republic is popping
off teddy is good times
i this is how i want my house to look
that'd be so cool right
that's the ultimate goal god that looks
amazing yeah i love this one great job
oh we got mdk from finland
one of the mods
oh man
oh my god
playing 2.00
freaking smushed dude oh my god
scrunched
just freaking that's wait one more time
it sound i love how they built that in
yeah why would they build that
[Music]
okay okay i get it so it's like they
have this testing chamber and it's like
if it all goes to [ __ ] we have this
button that we can press and it'll just
like crush whatever's happening i guess
but then it gets pressed accidentally
it's they definitely needed like a fail
safe i love the claymation vibe on this
you can actually see the bottles um like
moving all the materials look like
they're actually moving the lighting is
really cool the different layers the
bubbles on that uh sludge yeah the
sludge bubs are great fudge bubs
hey what's up sludge pup sludge bub
that's when we i knew like steam name
sludge bug
wow beautiful
cardboard vibes
um
we gotta we gotta give a shout out
it's a slugger knife slugger not yeah
all right what a slugger wow shout out
slugger not heard you were talking about
sluggers earlier we have been talking
about sluggers we've been talking about
sluggers champs busters pals
buds butts uh
skips scouts
um scoot skippers yeah definitely no
one's left behind
just just saying if you do need to run
to the restroom
that's a that's yeah i'm going that's a
possibility i gotta be so bad just watch
the computer oh god
chilling have a good time in there dude
thank you where is it oh um
so just go
through that little hallway door and
it's just right in front of you okay
right next to the green screen right
next to the green screen yeah in past
the green room
through the sound stage okay and um
there's a porta potty in the back cool
yeah past laura michael's office exactly
all right we doing it
hey peter is this is this a bathroom
situation where i should like wait for
you or should i keep going i could be in
there like 20 30 probably seconds
minutes
for real though um no obviously okay all
right
ah
shout outs y'all
we got psycho vfx spiderman kick day
with some good work pal hey
this dude really love spiderman
hey thanks man
thank you
thanks
[Laughter]
thanks that's really nice
all right dude you better go back it's
like before it slips out
um john we got john up in here has peter
left corridor
that's a personal question son we ain't
answering that
we ain't answering them questions
but i appreciate the super chat
i do very much
um what else we got over here happy to
answer any questions while our boy
is up in that bathroom we got 3 300
nearly 3 400 people up in the chat right
now absolutely incredible we're going
through the dynamic machines top 100 we
are going to choose top three us top
three international once we get through
all of these we're about
three fifths of the way through right so
probably in the next 30 minutes or so
we'll be wrapped up on all these renders
it'll be awesome
can't wait
absolutely cannot wait it's gonna be
awesome good times good times all around
streaming is a vibe streaming is hard
gotta keep the vibes up for
for hours
hours on end but
it's nice to have a bud with me you know
a real champ like peter france the man
himself
um for those of y'all who don't know i
just came out with a patreon like two
weeks ago a week ago
the link is in the description go check
it out i'm giving away my assets my
files my packs just came out with a vfx
tracker that allows you to track all
your vfx shots in a giant project
i got my surface imperfections up there
i got my concrete material pack i just
dropped up there i got my hdris
um project files from all these dynamic
or from all of these render contests up
there so it's a good time peter's got
one too peter's got a patreon it's in
the description
clint your bathroom is so nice i'm glad
you like it we also use the exact same
uh face cleanser really dude kim got me
on that stuff it's so good yes it's the
best yeah i like it i just bought it
like three days ago i'm like i need this
it's so nice because i used to like just
wash my face with soap and then just oh
god no it's so harsh it is hard to do
the same thing yeah it is harsh
guys skin care it's nice
all right let's uh
let's keep going
masa boy
finland
i love this one
oh that's great
that's wonderful it's giving me very uh
like tony hawk pro skater energy yep
that one underground level uh-huh yeah
it's like the first level right with the
helicopter i don't know is that the only
time about the warehouse it's like a
garage warehouse type thing yeah yeah
where you like grind the helicopter
rails and you go outside in the snow i
don't remember it was so long i was like
five years old
um this renter is great i love it yeah
i love skinheart vibes really good
lighting
good style all around um we got nathan
thanks for the super chat the stream's
great y'all are good co-hosts hell yeah
nice skip
slug
um
melvin
germany
oh that's wonderful it's darn good
it's darn good you gotta have a uh
carnival category and uh there is yeah
there is definitely
wow
very intricate
very well done great sound design just
like solid all around
all around
that lighter i love the lighter yeah so
check this out the way this contraption
works it flips the knob
which
when that opens oh my god it's like one
of those machines that yeah one of them
it pushes you see this lever on the on
the far right yeah it pushes that down
which you can't see it but it lights the
lighter
ah
the ball goes around so you see the
lighter on the bottom oh my bottom right
yeah
get rid of this
it goes up there wow oh that fuse looks
great yeah it looks really good
blasts it
look at look at the way it enters this
carousel
it's perfect and it bounces around and
everything it's perfect good god
and i don't like i could be wrong but is
there a weight change in like the way
that sways when the ball lands in there
we played again
it's like i can't tell like the one on
the left is moving a lot
a lot uh faster because it's loose
but the one on the right where the ball
is in feels like it's not moving as much
absolutely so well done like the amazing
oh
yeah great job melvin from germany um
also i think been a long time long time
champ with the uh
with the community here what a total
champ what a champ
che from taiwan what you got oh my god
[Music]
jesus christ yeah i just rewatched
ratatouille oh that's one of the best
movies ever i agree it's i agree perfect
it should have won best picture of the
year it came out it's it's well pixar
has just graded everything to do but
ratatouille that movie specifically is
like perfect it's the best yeah
oh god
i don't like food yeah i love it
god this is fantastic
yup che
absolutely beautiful
so much going on the color like the
subtle color contrast here is great
fantastic just a fancy old restaurant
yeah the composition the colors
the way everything is laid out is so
pretty the machinery yeah it's beautiful
good stuff yeah good stuff
um john we got a super chat from ya
uh imagine all the artists working on a
game together that would be super yeah
that'd be sick super cool that'll be
sick
all right
uh phillip
felipe
thank you thank you for the super chat
shout out to my cousin
peter
i think it's peter peter from sweden
hope he made top 100 i guess we'll see
we shall see there has been a peter
already i wonder if it's the that
particular peter could be
shout outs to cuz
old cousin
let's see where we're at
france francoise
oh man
[Applause]
oh wow
i i gotta do it i gotta do it yeah
golden some golden glows yeah
so good that's fantastic the 2.5 d
mm-hmm
it's the sound design that gets me it's
so good
[Applause]
that's so fun mm-hmm
it really is
that's great fantastic job shout outs
france is that that's probably not how
you say francois francois
yeah we got germany andre
[Music]
oh my god the base
holy [ __ ]
[Music]
oh my god
that's so fun
yeah and it's really well constructed i
was i was reading like in the on the
discord server people were commenting or
is it either on youtube
um commenting on
how well the mechanical machinery and
design
appeared to be real seriously yes all of
the hinges are in like the exact right
spot of where they would have to be for
this to function yeah
super cool it's a very simple setup but
like i love this like
it's almost that
bank teller tube
thing
you like the mail shoot or yes exactly
exactly i love how it rotates towards
camera uh-huh that's nice good stuff
andre yeah shout outs from germany we
got another germany render ben
where you at
such a different vibe from that last one
yeah
wow
that's fantastic bringing me back to the
good old days of uh making little
electronic things
this is like
exactly how it would be done probably
with all the switches and motors and
levers and electrical wiring and whatnot
good job ben yeah that's great i just
love that homemade vibe
it's so cool the way the cardboard bends
and everything when it hits the way the
pencils uh
like rotate how they would if they were
taped there that way oh yeah right here
yeah so subtle but it's like very good
attention to detail on this
does the cardboard bend
um a little bit a little bit yeah the
cardboard kind of like dips
oh that's fantastic just a little bit
yeah i love that mm-hmm great job well
they even got a lego piece in there yeah
solid stuff great stuff yeah yeah good
they're from germany dear vinder
oh that's fantastic
there this was the one with the sleepy
guy
uh that you were talking about earlier
yeah check out this guy right here oh
this little sleeper yeah
and he's like what was that so he wakes
up a couple times and then he goes back
to this uh-huh that's so great yeah
dear fender from germany good stuff i
love these characters yeah has a lot of
character yeah i love the feeling of
this
really cool i love all the little
stories in here it really paints a
picture of like what this little world
is like exactly yeah exactly uh john
thank you for the super chat there could
be a lord of the rings inspired
community challenge in the spirit of the
new series coming out well i bet you
could get a fat check from amazon for
that
could be
there could be one but who knows jeff if
you're watching
jeff bezos oh yes
first name basis i see first name bezos
last name
amazon that's like a good lyric
first name i'm on a first name bezos
with jeff baker
i'm on a first name basis
oh oh my god sorry one more time yeah um
this is uh
from germany
really good pinball that's amazing yeah
really good pinball version i'm always
amazed at like art imitating other art
like in a movie if there's a commercial
for something that doesn't exist that
they had to make for the movie yeah it's
like it's hard to do that really well in
like making a pinball machine that
actually feels like something that would
exist
in the real world and has like its own
vibe in addition to the art it exists in
is like
really impressive very true yeah you
have to come up with a whole
pinball machine like people
spend their lives building pinball
machines like that's somebody's job yeah
to design that yeah and you did that in
3d and made it work and textured it and
lit it and it's beautiful so congrats
that's amazing yeah
thrust thrust friction
i love how the labels are tripping off
towards the bottom where the marble has
rolled oh for real
yeah like right here it's like the
marbles always rolling past this oh wow
sticker peel yeah that's really cool
that's wonderful another germany render
we got ennis what you got
whoa
that's a really interesting style yep it
reminds me of the intro
um's um cinematic from wipeout pure for
the psp
it like builds a really cool uh hover
hover race car essentially and it but it
all gets animated on and it's in this
really soft white
um with sparse color
kind of a vibe sort of mirrors edgy yeah
exactly
i just love really nice yeah it's so
clean it's beautiful
shout outs ennis good stuff very very
good stuff
another germany conrad
oh my god is it indiana jones
that's amazing yeah wow
really cool the chase oh my god yeah
that's done so well
that dive is so cool and he smacks into
the walls
it's very much like a wes anderson
claymation splat yeah
looney tunes man yeah
dude that's so good and the animation of
indy is very impressive it is it's very
good oh spike pit up there too
yeah the way he swings conrad is very
nice
that's amazing great job
great lighting too yeah very fun nice
volumetrics
uh spain
we got guillermo
oh this one
jesus yep that's insane
it feels so random it it does you know
what i mean it everything
happens for a reason and yeah it feels
super random but somehow it still works
yeah it's crazy i'm so curious how
this person thought of this and like
executed yeah so it hits the book and
even there's even animation on the book
when it hits the book so small
but it rolls down it hits the bowl i
have those exact bowls the classic
classic eye cables it hits the cup right
and it's trapped right so where's it
gonna go god the physics on how it
slides the cup are perfect yep perfect
rotation it knocks the apple which
hits the spoon
and keeps the ball going
and then that falls down
through the knife through the cups wow
and calls it a day like
the lighting the rendering the animation
the sequence the contraption is so good
on this one um i love the choice of uh
choice of tiles in the back those yeah
really reflective white tiles look nice
it's beautiful good stuff caramel
excellent physics also yep
michael from germany
that's wonderful that is beautiful it's
super beautiful the lighting and the
color yeah just has me wanting to stare
at this forever
wow in the uh
some of it's like 2.5 d or is it
like those barrels and the way they're
animated yeah it's like at a lower fps
looks really nice yeah it's super cool
so good that's amazing yeah yeah great
sound zone too agreed good stuff michael
from germany shout outs
3 500 people in the chat we're still
going strong
thank you all for being here for joining
us
germany we got valerie
so good that's amazing i love this one
yeah
now some of these have sound design but
i think there's a thing with davinci
that
won't
play the sound so i'll have to figure
that out for the top 100 so if you don't
hear sound and you know you did sound i
reached out to a couple y'all no worries
um but look at this yeah like i love the
design it's like ren fair vibes
um it's so beautiful
great work valerie
yeah great composition like triangular
composition really nice
yeah it's fun like i want to be here
i want to be at like this fair or this
play or whatever this is
super much in uh shrek when they go into
the castle and they like get their photo
taken at that thing where the doors open
up it's like
oh and then the little guys start
dancing around yeah yeah totally
totally
there's my face right up in here chillin
little shout outs
valerie that is great yeah
congratulations you should be proud of
that yeah seriously
india we got
akash
[Applause]
whoa
wonderful grace-centered composition yep
and really unique contraption i hadn't
seen anything like this
wow
super cool
akash you should be proud beautiful as
well very beautiful well-lit
well-rendered well-designed
sound sound designs on point like
no one did that no one did this little
circle thing and like did this like
weird ripple
that's amazing not weird but like
it's perpetual motion machine it's super
cool this looks like something straight
out of like architectural digest or
something like that yes absolutely
um we got a super chat from old zen love
your channel
uh can we have a challenge on cg nature
vegetation it's so overlooked i feel
what are your thoughts on real versus cg
nature wow well preferably like to be in
that real nature you know get that
oxygen oh yeah but um i i love me some
good nature shots
um
it could be cool to do like a forest
thing a forest themed
challenge i don't know yeah yeah
um but thank you for the super chat old
zen appreciate you
akash great work very good stuff
oh man i say that name
oh my god
brandon
from florida jesus
that's messed up it's messed up wow
this is just
this is
that's incredible
everything amazing artistry yeah i mean
all of these
like agrees yeah agreed
this is incredible yeah the atmosphere
the lighting the rendering the design
the animation it feels alive it's moving
there's like
the color is very subtle very filmic
the contraption works really cool
there's a bunch of layers to it this is
firing on all cylinders for me that i i
like want to know the story behind this
i know
what is it like what the hell so creepy
and there's this little droid like
sorting parts here
yeah wow great stuff brandon good stuff
fantastic
i'm excited for this next one
[Music]
[Applause]
i don't want to talk about it
i don't want to talk so so what's going
on on that tv in the background all
right so look for all of you who don't
know ren did a submission uh at corridor
he made top 100 he made top 100 so and
he legit made top 100 this is a great
render
very well done um ren and
shoot
shoot
it was another dude was it matt it's not
that it wasn't no it was the new guy
we're so bad
in my defense i've never met this person
i should know this
someone's going to tell me in the chat
anyway
great work here great work here
is jordan his name is george jordan
that's what it was
jordan
there there's already a jordan
look and that that's how i remembered
yeah oh okay that's how i remembered
shout outs jordan jordan and ren uh put
this together absolutely incredible the
atmosphere the fire the sim jordan did
this crazy houdini sim down here there's
physics animation like physical
like
they're rag dolls but they're still
animated it's amazing yeah like they're
trying to hang on on the far right here
you see like
come on now
you see the like they're hitting they're
clipping boom bouncing off the edge
there yeah it's super good
good stuff
um and then so sorry what was happening
on the back tv okay so basically
red came over one day because i
challenged him to smash bros on the
stream and he drove over here
and we played a best of three
wow and it was bowser versus ness
and technically i mean he won the first
game okay
of three he won the first game of three
okay and then what happened
and then he freaking screen capped it
and put it on the tv
okay what about the next two games oh i
won those ones oh so i won the best of
three don't worry about that you know
uh man yeah um well
uh i would challenge you but i don't
know i want to make sure you're in a
good place before
we'll get it next time we'll get it i'll
have the new capture card we can switch
over to if you're feeling like good you
know mentally physically yeah yeah
because i want to make sure
you know you don't want to take it too
hard when i
destroy it i mean coming from freaking a
bowser junior maine that's a that's a
lot of talk oh okay
a lot of talk there wow really insulting
the name
i'll talk no walk let's see
dude
you know what they call me what
champ
[Laughter]
[ __ ] yeah you know it's true you're
right damn it the audience voted right
that's true
[Applause]
peandido from indonesia
wicked cool render
that's fantastic yeah good stuff
really intricate nice surface
imperfections well lit
good contraption you get your lighting
popping very creative contraption yeah
like dropping a bunch of different stuff
here
multi-faceted multi-tiered contraption
that's what i like to see
lots of lighting
lighting solid
got your blue orange contrast in there
your daylight and your tungsten down
below looking good hell yeah
great job the red complements everything
nicely yeah pinandito congrats good
stuff good stuff
fabian
from the uk oh another portal
wow that's wonderful
very clever that's great very well done
looks beautiful sound design yeah the
lighting's safe that nice like slightly
green fluorescent such a good look it's
the best
that's so good the animation on that
ball is perfect
good work fabian that was fantastic i
lied there's two portal renders in this
top 100
i mean i'm not mad about it i love
portal oh yeah
sick good stuff
wilmer from venezuela
my goodness
wow
that's a golden glow for me all right
wow
super cool that's wonderful got the
dynamic machines logo in there oh that's
what that is yeah shout out to go for
this yeah so p and y p and y um they
have a really cool team over there and i
believe it was jordan from pny put
together this logo did this cool little
thing so they threw it in there it's
awesome
that's super cool i love
the way the machine works at the bottom
it's just working so hard trying it's
best
oh that's wonderful great job
this is the best idea you've ever had oh
dude it's great shout outs to benq
lighting on these guys yeah
gareth oh my god us
[Music]
that's amazing that's such a good idea
sorry that's not really cool
they look like a um
what's that uh pastry um
flop not a falafel definitely not a flaw
a macaroon a macaroon
looks like falafel dude yes a macaroon a
high-tech uh falafe macaroon
the design dude look at this that's a
design
yeah
um
classic sci-fi design yeah i love the
yellow and white yep
such a good vibe
really nice lighting great animation
good rendering the way the springs go
and they kind of boom yeah good stuff
gareth from the us excellent shout outs
to you
oh hell yeah here we go
lego town
that's wonderful sweet love that yeah
huge fan of legos love the fact they
could actually build this with legos
so sick that's amazing yeah good color
good lighting
very fun great lighting
love the way it bounces off the white in
the back
uh we got a super chat shout outs to
milan loving each and every one of these
can't wait to see who won top threes
also peter loved the new tutorial
oh hell yeah unreal what unreal can do
thank you i appreciate that i can't wait
to watch it yeah hell yeah yeah go check
out the new video on my channel y'all
uh the link is the link to peter's
channel is in the description go check
that out yes yeah always man
all right we got dolan green up next
congrats on top 100
from the u.s what you got
wow
that's wonderful
beautiful
that like reverse simulation to get the
uh
very satisfying
super satisfying there was the
captain dissolution video on that you
remember that one
very clever
yeah i love the sound design on this
why is any sound design of like a lot of
things being poured it's always so
satisfying it's very satisfying it's
like tiny tickling of the ear you know
shout outs dahlin great job
another harry potter
dude
oh man
so good great that's a golden glow dude
this one is so good robert from
australia
ah there's so much i love about it first
off the theme and the vibe amazing
the render quality lighting amazing
simulation there we got the fire i don't
know if that's action vfx probably but
it's
amazing it's incredible yeah like that's
a really good fire the viscosity of that
drop is so nice yeah
like i i want to like hold it in my
hands like this stuff yeah
um
so check this out look how this works
alright so
you have let me go frame by frame here
so you have the ball drop in
it rolls off it knocks the potion
right now hold on this because you have
the ball coming off the edge yep
now it knocks this potion
i believe and it hits the chandelier
bonk
bonk okay now the book
is tilting and while the book is tilting
you got the drop coming out yeah
love that drop now the ball lands in
this teleport bag
okay
so all this happens at once oh
the book knocks the bottle so that the
drop lands right in the bottle
okay and while this is happening we're
gonna have a teleport boom you see it's
loading
oh my god boom teleport shoots out
knocks this shelf
hits the chandelier again
this potion hits the book makes it
disappear
as this blows up
and this ball falls now the book's gone
so the ball can fall through
knock some more potions knocks a candle
over jesus
and it starts to fire oh my god son and
that's crazy that's incredible yeah the
detail in the animation just the world
the vibes the cobwebs the lighting
that's wild yeah robert great stuff
great stuff mm-hmm wow
uh milan we got another super chat from
yeah hell yeah no that's the same one
from last time
um but old zen we got another super chat
from you what are the top five slash 10
books you recommend every environment
artists need to have
beginner to pro so you had some books in
your videos please help
now that's assuming i have read five to
ten books on exactly environment art
i uh no nope
do you have any environment art books
i i know zero environment art books i
i don't know man there's uh tutorials
tuts tuts ae dots
that's a shout out that was a long time
ago that was a long time ago um no i
mean yeah there's a lot of great
tutorials i wish i had something
valuable to say about this but i really
don't um i mean obviously looking at
real life reference and just trying to
copy that as best as possible
yeah
um
now if you're talking about art books
environment art books you're talking
like photo books of different locations
around the world like i can talk about
those
um there's like some solid ones uh
what is it the
shoot something city
the lost city forbidden city abandoned
city uh city of darkness there's the
book called city of darkness and it's
like photographs of
kowloon walled city which is this like
super dense packed
city in hong kong it's torn down it was
torn out of 95 but it's like
dude it's so it had the highest
population per like square whatever
packed into one spot goodness and this
photographer went through and like took
pictures of everyone who lived there
there's like
the mailman ducking under pipes of steam
to like deliver mail there's
dentists in there they have like uh
like the health area where they're
giving shots and like the butcher and
everyone's just in this dark dingy thing
there's people on the roof with like
satellites sticking up on the roof and
there's kids playing
there's walkways and it's crazy that
sounds amazing city of darkness uh
revisited take a look at that that's
really cool it's a good one that's a
really good one
there's a bunch of others um
i can get in all that stuff maybe a
little bit later but yeah
good question thanks for the super chat
moving on
we got from the czech republic vladislav
whoa
oh my god i love it
wow
it's really uh abstract
and at the end of the day look it's just
the slide but it's about the most
satisfying slide i've seen so far i
how much do you want to just take a pair
of scissors to that thing just like
so good
wow that is an incredible simulation i
know it's all rubbery yeah
super sick oh wow i love the center
lighting too it like really makes the uh
the front bits stand out totally the
dark side
that's really nice yeah
good stuff wow love it shout out
vladislav
uh we got
igor igor from ukraine
um dude this one
ridiculous
that gets the golden glow so nice that
is beautiful
that is like some of the most satisfying
lighting i have seen it's i want to be
in this world 24 7.
that's absolutely gorgeous minecraft
doesn't even look this good
well if you have uh rich kid minecraft
okay yes yeah that is that a thing yeah
you can uh get like rtx enabled
minecraft okay it looks exactly like
that and it's incredible oh yeah
yeah this one
the colors
so good i love
it
i love how they popped out the
individual voxels on the blocks so that
it has some definition and the light
catches the side of it like right there
oh heck yeah on there and stuff good eye
looks really nice through the spider
webs and the depth of it is really nice
too yes i want to be back here i want to
be back in that little clubhouse area
beautiful portal so cool
a freaking little zombie chase it's so
nice yeah beautiful great stuff uh we
got another super chat from zap
zap anderson sorry i didn't get to meet
you clint when i visited corridor for
seagraph 2019 i did meet peter and the
rest of the video nice it's great to
meet you man heck yeah
um c graph that'll be one i'd like to go
to at some point yeah
all right uh hue from korea
what's going on congrats on top 100
[Music]
super cool i love the way the lighting
changes over the course of the shot
the volumetric lights the god rays and
how they're being kind of obstructed by
the different objects
[Music]
there's a beat to that hold on yeah a
little bit
[Music]
that's fantastic
beautiful yeah it reminds me there's a
series called i think it's called anna
music like animated music and it's
contraptions like this that shoot these
balls out and it makes songs and it's so
satisfying that's really cool and i'm
wondering if hue
was inspired by it but
the lighting is solid the contraption
solid the animation like everything on
this is just incredible hats off
hats off
super sick
next up we have doane
from
vietnam
congrats on making that top 100.
jesus
yeah that's
nuts that's one thick slide that is a
thick ass slider
uh-huh
the refinery man god i love the scale of
it it feels huge it's massive yeah the
uh
that's so good the lighting and the
animation and the flag and the cloth and
like that little walkway i want to walk
up it yeah
this really this whole challenge really
scratches that itch of
uh you know those christmas stores where
they have all of the little pieces of
towns and like the railroads going
through them and things like that you
just look at it and you're like oh yeah
it's like that feeling it's like little
secret areas
dude secret areas that's the [ __ ] yeah
are you gonna have a secret air in your
game
yeah
definitely
oh my god i'm gonna talk about that uh
david croucher thank you for the super
chat dudes you missed my last super chat
but i forgive you because we're both
awesome oh no
i'll scroll up
i'll scroll up as far as i can sorry
sorry luis fernandez i see you thank you
for the super chat
i can't even i can't even scroll that
far david it happens man it happens
um shout outs to you though thank you
for the super chat sorry mr last one
thanks for the support appreciate you
very very much
incredible
all right
doug wilson
from australia um i love this one
[Applause]
that foreground
that's beautiful
clubhouse vibes shrek swamp vibes yeah
oh my i love the foreground i am the
foreground is so good yeah and this
dude's cranking it up here
he's going to town on the crank a little
parrot
oh yeah so the parrot rides the line
oh my gosh he's coming towards you
that's incredible mm-hmm oh my this is
my favorite one so far yeah doug that's
great job done super sick good god i
could watch this for hours
in the depth it goes back so far yeah
it's beautiful you can see the trees
back there and everything
incredible yeah i love it
hold on hold on no hold on now
yep
uh let's see where are we at
here we are here we are
moxie
australia
oh my goodness it makes like an old
fashioned or something it does yeah
that's my go-to drink it's a good one
that's amazing
yeah so check this out this is i always
love tracking these complicated ones so
the ball drops in
hits the slide so the ice right triggers
the ice yeah the ice shoot by the way
the the frost built up on the freezer
there looks incredible oh heck yeah like
on the edge right here and everything on
the back
so the ice goes down the chute as the
ball is still on the top third coming
down
the rail yeah
and the ice let's see it's popping down
there yeah on the right goes through the
scissors so the ball
hits on the left it hits uh
the matchbox or batteries orbits gum or
something pops the
nail or the screw out to pull the bin
yeah to get the second ball going
as the drink starts pouring wow and
notice on the right
scissors chop the herbs oh my god it
falls into the drink wow
on the bottom
everything falls in
to form the perfect old fashion
it's super cool amazing i don't know if
it is an old-fashioned i don't think old
fashions have like leaves in them right
i have no idea
yeah i'm curious which drink this is
that's amazing it's really good that's
so good maxime
great from australia yeah
zoe milligan
oh my goodness super sick
i think this was another one with sound
that like didn't work but we'll get it
working for top 100 no worries there
wow
that's beautiful yeah
i love that it feels like that old hotel
yeah you know totally
kicks the boot love the boot yeah great
idea really good render quality
good stuff so
yeah excellent mm-hmm
go cool from india
sweet name
oh wow this one's great
the sunglasses yeah that's good that's
gotta go
wow that's a good one so very good one
lots of personality yes let's track this
one this one's a fun one to track too
the ball comes in
triggers that wall it hits that flag and
triggers the red dominoes down below
very mouse trap ask yes
so then that hits the butt the dominoes
hit the button which opens that box
ah
and then we get this fallen in
and it triggers the sunglasses
and then this little yellow
pin right here that it triggers i think
that is the hat
oh no no the button
this button right here this silver
button presses and triggers the hat
that's amazing yeah wow and the color
yeah this one is incredible i dig it
very very good
wow it's just fun to look at
ken from malaysia this one's crazy yeah
whoa
oh my god
yeah definitely
oh my god
yeah
wow
pretty insane
the animation the render the atmosphere
the effects the synths
the
story
that's incredible yeah if uh
man if you played half-life alex dude no
this looks exactly like a little health
thing that you like
it's like a little health file and it
has this creepy little thing in it and
you like put it into a machine and then
put your hand on it like heals you oh
that's cool looks exactly like that
that's sick
that's amazing yeah it's absurd it's so
well done ken from malaysia is
absolutely insane
wow
let's see
brandon lee
not bruce lee's son
unfortunately
yep
wow let's take another look
what an intricate contraption yeah
really nice
i love this
yeah it feels very
realistic and very possible yes like
it's gen it's generating energy the
light bulb goes off once the ball gets
in there
this one's cool that's really cool yeah
love that
good stuff brandon
clay from the u.s clay won second place
on the dynamic machines
alternate realities nice
oh damn
damn
love that sound design yeah really nice
so you remember the uh
harvest render where the dudes pushing
of course same guy oh no same guy yeah
excellent so this one oh whoa
hold on now
bear with me get back to that hero
that's awesome it's so crazy reminds me
of the uh indiana jones disney ride oh
yeah it totally does
um this reminds me of i'm playing hades
and it totally reminds me that game
maybe a little bit of diablo but the
colors are really nice it's that like um
orange purple
vibe i love it
it's really really good yeah
really good
i love how it passes through the little
spot there it's very much like mini
golfing when you can't see the ball for
a second yeah pops out and you're like
ah i love it i love it
yeah very very good
oh great physics on the bridge
yeah super sick clay good work very good
work
so that
it concludes i believe the top 100 i
feel like that deserves a round of
applause yes
absolutely ah
great job y'all
ah my neck must be exhausted so here's
what we're gonna do we have to announce
the top three winners u.s and top three
international and it was very difficult
to choose these winners but
um here's what we're gonna do we're
gonna take a short break
two to five minutes hang there hang in
there hang with us um we're gonna come
back or announce these winners they're
gonna win some amazing prizes from
nvidia and pny as well as some limited
edition art prints from myself with top
tier patreon access for a year
um and then we're gonna get into a
little weekly challenge stuff but uh
everyone take a moment chill out
hang out with a chat enjoy yourself use
the restroom get a drink we'll be back
in five minutes to announce the winners
of this thing so we'll see you all very
very very very soon don't move those
butts
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
all right um
we're back
restrooms have been used lines have been
ripped
what
what
[Laughter]
kidding just kidding
good times um i think it's time to take
a bite of banana bread
i finished oh you crushed yours dude
it's so good it's so good
shout outs to vj killing it with the
super chat these like these big numbers
from your boy bj over here congrats on
top 100 waiting for the final
compilation
comes out next weekend
top 100 compilation with sick music it's
going to be nice sound design
it's been great and then the week after
that all renders four hours long nearly
2 000 renders excuse me insane
nuts no the stream's not over we got to
announce
the
top three
us top three international
and um
i'm excited so hell yeah let's just get
into it i'm nervous i'm nervous for
everyone
i told you i have covered
ah
um
he's definitely lying
um but for real though
he might not be um
okay starting with us
all right so
in third place
for the united states of america
the third best render in all this whole
thing in my personal opinion
i'm looking at i agree by the way for
what it's worth nobody asked but i agree
that's good to know yeah good enough
cool
um shout outs to nvidia and pny because
they're edition out a 2.5 inch sata 3
ssd it's 500 gigs yep 500 gigabytes
ssd
for your boy so whoever receives that
can back up their stuff with us
very true
yeah third place for the u.s winning the
500 gig 2.5 inch side of three ssd is
rocky wong from
united states
killing it with the coffee render let me
get this freaking too good yep
build now this coffee machine the
lighting is beautiful render quality is
beautiful the contraption is
is complicated you know it serves a
purpose it's doing a thing
everything here is just firing on all
cylinders congratulations rocky wong you
got third place on this thing
you getting that 500 gig 2.5 just out of
three ssd from pny nvidia killing it
back up your stuff
dude you're good at these brand reads
i'm trying dude i'm trying
oh man
um congratulations
rocky wong
third place us good stuff oh yeah good
stuff
all right
moving on second place so second place
u.s
is going to win from p and y and
one they're gonna win something right
and it's probably a one terabyte pcie m2
nvme ssd
that's a lot of words to basically say
you're going to
back up all your stuff even more now
and read and write speeds read and write
speeds of up to six and a half gigs
that's why so like per second so drag
and drop six gigs done
it's fast i want one
um
so shout outs to second place us
goes to
stephen potinski
frogtown
i
freaking love this one yes
yes so good it's so good i want a movie
that takes place in this world i know
it's so much fun i love the color the
contraption the world like the
characters the sculpture of whatever
frog god they yeah like pray to
yeah it's so good steven uh potinsky
congratulations for second place you're
getting that uh let me see if i can say
without looking at the list a one
terabyte pcie
m2
ssd congratulations oh yeah
second place baby good stuff
and finally
finally
after all this time
after all this time
first place
winning the grand prize from
nvidia and pny
a nvidia quadro rtx 5000
this is a beefy boy it is a card that
will get you a bunch
of video ram you're not gonna you're not
gonna have to worry about uh
you know watching that video ram too
much at all because you're gonna pack
them scenes full of detail it's going to
be sweet no more instanced meshes no
every mesh is an individual
file yeah and it's like the geometry is
just
it's over the top you don't even touch
it exactly don't even worry about it
um so coming in first place
we have for the united states all right
right after this we're doing top three
international
brandon
troyer whoa
ah wonderful
yeah so good
the the render quality
the design
the animation the detail the lighting
it's volumetric i know the atmosphere
like it's look at the detail when the
eye moves down you can see it like
illuminates the fog there in the middle
it's amazing
fantastic render yeah absolutely
incredible brandon troyer
congratulations you getting that
graphics card baby
congratulations shout outs keep up the
good work
keep it up
heck yeah heck yeah congrats y'all
congratulations
to the u.s winners of dynamic machines
but we ain't done because we have top
three international as well um as some
of you know as most of you know the
physical prizes could not be sent out um
from any nvidia and pny to international
um for xyz reasons you know sending
graphics cards to other countries is
kind of a thing really it's kind of a
thing interesting yeah i didn't know huh
it's not even for sale in some countries
weird i don't know is it like an
anti-crypto thing i have no idea weird
um but anyway
what i'm doing here
is giving out um three
of god it's so confusing three come over
here
um
of uh three of my
uh archival
limited edition
photo prints they're gonna be three of
my renders uh the
well i guess i have them here yeah let
me show you real quick
all right
so three prints for y'all to hang on
your wall for my international artists
here
the first one
is gonna be
my alternate realities
basically crisp son i'm gonna sign it
i'm gonna write a letter to you it's
gonna be great
um we got
another one here we've got three
we've got the mortality run
one god i love that one
boom
right it's coming to you
shipping it your way
and finally the
parallel
dimensions
print
so good all right wow all three i'm
gonna sign them what an artiste look at
those
incredible shout outs to sammy's
oh you gotta put in the same sammy's
dude chill let's chill over sammy's
samus is great yeah i got some stuff
there
um you get your film developer too oh
very nice i'm gonna roll this up and
we're gonna announce these winners so on
top of that
they're also going to win a year
a year's worth of pro tier patreon
got all my assets project files
yeah art reviews uh you know shout outs
oh everything
everything i got goes up to the pro tier
patreon uh link in the description just
uh just released it last week hell yeah
um
so without further ado
let's get
these top three international
starting with third place
third place
yes we got
peter's favorite
from australia
doug wilson
god it's so good it's beautiful oh my
god it is
everything i want in life
yeah i just want to be chilling in a
clubhouse with like
secret areas and little fun houses very
vertical
yes cats in here oh god damn so good
doug wilson congratulations fantastic
job amazing
you're getting the limited edition
prints i have yet to figure out how many
copies i'm going to sell of these
versions of these tiny versions maybe 15
or 20 um
but it looks like you got number three
all right issue number three of all
three of those prints so congratulations
doug you got the patreon pro tier as
well you earned it this render is
incredible i love that foreground
so good
congratulations doug wilson for third
place international
after third place comes second
um we're just getting right to it
so
yeah we're just getting right to it
we're just getting right to it from
taiwan second place international
getting all those three prints in the
pro tier patreon
here we go
cha cha cha chi yay
chai chang
ridiculous
did you see that little piece of bread
sliding down there yeah that bread chute
that's amazing
congratulations che
it's amazing like the contraption is
complicated and advanced there's a lot
of things going on your animation is
perfect your materials are perfect you
got your subtle surface imperfections in
here your sound design is incredible
um
your color very subtle color contrast
yeah yeah like that like it's red green
but very or like pink green kind of yeah
it's perfect it's it's amazing
congratulations chase second place
international hats off to you
absolutely beautiful
um
great work solid work
be sending them prints your way
and finally
first place international
it's going to someone okay
is it it's going to someone really
wren moved
back to vietnam
you're kidding no no no no
no no no no no no no oh my god can it's
it's not ren ren is not winning
that'd be the opposite that'd be like
the most opposite
wait you said the most upset so you're
saying ren was the last the last place
i'm not saying random's last place but
you're also not not saying that
i'm not not saying that so he's not
first place right
first place goes to
someone from australia
that someone's name
is robert coutts
dude i don't know why we didn't have the
golden glow oh yeah what the hell the
whole time well i mean this is like the
one yeah for sure yeah um robert this
is so good this makes me want to play
every video game in this style ever
um it makes me want to watch kiki's
delivery service again that's my
favorite it's so good
it makes me want to play like
i don't know breath of the wild i know
it's a little off but like
harry potter harry potter yeah like
the the render quality the contraption
the series of events everything that
went into this render is so good
fantastic
hats off if i had them
congratulations robert for first place
international you're getting those three
prints
good stuff and congrats to everyone
congrats all y'all yeah all around first
second third us international and all
the top 100 artists congrats on making
top 100 and look if y'all didn't make
top 100 don't worry it's all good uh
this month the 28th august 28th we got
the all renderers montage coming out
it's gonna be four hours of every
submission all the six submissions every
single one is amazing
um and it's really the joy to watch like
all those renderers absolutely um and
before we call it
for those of you who didn't win this
thing
pny and nvidia
they're super sick really they've been
put
you're saying they've been they've been
a pleasure to work with on the first
render challenge we did parallel
dimensions and the third one dynamic
machines this one right here um what
they're doing is for those of you who
didn't win for those of you who didn't
have a chance to submit any art for this
um we're doing a freaking raffle right
and they're giving away more ssds more
hardware all the good stuff let me show
you what's going down dude i might have
to you know
let me pull it on up
um so many displays where are we at
here here we are get it together bam
so this is called expanding machines
part two of this thing um it's a little
raffle situation i'm back says he's back
i'm back absolutely um rules and
resources so basically what y'all are
doing
is you come down here and there's a
bunch of different ways to
essentially get like a ticket a raffle
ticket or a point it's gonna be a random
drawing 14 ways to enter so you can have
14 points in the raffle essentially
again it's going to be a random drawing
on i believe the 30th
of august is when this ends could be the
28th the link is in the description i
should know this
anyway i'll double check that in a
second first place y'all getting that p
and y one terabyte m2 nvme uh ssd this
is read write speeds of up to six gigs
absolutely incredible
you got yourself the nvidia shield tv
pro which basically turns any tv into a
smart tv you got all your apps watch all
your shows
um it'll actually like 4k display and
everything so
super sick here and then two 512
gigabyte
um usb 3.1 flash drive so four winners
on this it ends i believe
in the description of the video it
should be the 30th i believe is when
this contest ends
um this is a raffle random raffle
for y'all um
so yeah if you didn't have a chance to
enter or if you didn't have any art you
know this could be your chance to win
some of this cool stuff from nbnpy
nvidia and pny shout outs to them it's
been a pleasure working with them
um
the link is in the description let's go
check it out
peter oh yeah that was amazing
it's been a pleasure champ champ slider
bud
[Laughter]
that was too good thank you that was too
good uh it truly has been a great time
thanks for having me yeah absolutely um
so the last thing last thing i'm going
to do is wrap this out
uh we have the weekly challenge as you
all know and you peter you are more than
welcome to hang out here i'm just going
to probably take 10 minutes to announce
the weekly challenge later i'm we're
getting breakfast we are getting
breakfast after this i'm not going to
skip out on breakfast dude not at a
2 p.m breakfast that would i mean that's
the move honestly that's what we're
doing i'm getting breakfast i don't know
about you
yeah
absolutely
um really though congratulations to all
y'all this was incredible i can't wait
for top 100 montage next week all
runners montage the week after that but
um before we wrap this out let's talk
about the weekly challenge winners um
the weekly challenge
what's the weekly challenge the weekly
challenge is something i do every single
week on my discord the link is in the
description
and um
it's basically uh you get a prompt every
single week and this does the prompt
this week was brutalist architecture oh
yeah hot hot super hot
so
you had to you know come up with your
best brutalist architecture style render
and five y'all are winning the uh
the challenge winner role on the discord
server which unlocks the full discord um
we did a re-haul on the discord
and essentially now
there is a pro tier access on discord to
be tied with the patreon so in there we
got the lounge we got game night uh we
got ask me anything we got art review
um so you get full access if you win
the top five of the weekly challenge
so let's just get to it all right um
first winner of the weekly challenge is
naz
with this awesome piece of art
really cool color very nice yeah good um
good design and really nice composition
center composition i'm a fan of
you got the light hitting the area of
like
the focus in the center here the blue
ambient light is really nice it's
beautiful yeah it's really nice very
very beautiful
um so congrats naz you're getting the
challenge winner role unlocking the full
discord for you
it's gonna be a good time
second place in no particular order this
is no particular order here
um we
have
those almost mcdonald's
a really cool mini short oh wow by m
design goodness
oh the shadow of that tree it's so so
beautiful
goodness gracious
oh my god yeah those trees i know
that design is crazy
[Music]
yep
gorgeous
shout outs indesign good stuff if you
all are looking for ways to challenge
yourself and uh
you know take on new challenges every
every single week the weekly challenge
is a great way to do so um and i feature
the best art from it
every single week on the stream so shout
outs to mdesign
for that very very nice
moving on the third winner of the weekly
challenge
is
mcmuffin oh
really nice interior gorgeous yeah
beautiful little spotlight some
volumetrics up top here very reminiscent
of the show loki uh tva yeah it's this
huge
sprawling like uh office building with
like very like brutalist architecture
like this it looks very similar it's
beautiful marvel's loki
yeah is this okay i got you gotcha yeah
it's so good
um shout outs mcmuffin you get the
challenge winner roll this week
unlocking the full discord server good
stuff
very good stuff
two more for you we got
our boy
the moderator himself ronan
oh my god i know
that is so gorgeous i know it's great
that's like if the venice bathrooms were
like really nice
wait
venice you know the venice beach
bathrooms i don't oh okay never mind
like if they were super nice it'd be
like this okay gotcha
yeah the lighting here is top-notch the
color is top-notch
super sick very very nice um
shout out to ronan one of the mods
knocking it out um we also have a super
chat from jackson roberts congrats to
everybody on your renders
um
oh render is what his graffiti said that
wasn't yeah okay we all put in such
great work you all did y'all killed it
yeah honestly
um and finally here
weekly challenge winner number five in
no particular order
getting the challenge winner roll for
this week is
the one and only one dead duck gorgeous
yeah wow good stuff
absolutely beautiful photo realistic
composition color that ground is
incredible i know
it's really good it's very very good
yeah
congratulations to all y'all it's all
five of you naz m design mcmuffin ronin
and one dead duck killing it with the
art
this week for the weekly challenge keep
it up yo getting that challenge on a
roll
how you feeling
i feel accomplished yeah
it feels good it was a that was a haul
that was a
how long was that three hours and 18
minutes wow we did it hell yeah yep okay
champ okay slugger slugger bud
butterworthy
good stuff y'all um
we'll hang out for the next five minutes
we'll chill oh yeah finish these drinks
i don't know
cheers uh we'll do a little q a if you
have any questions for us
we'll hang for a little bit and then
we're gonna call it we're gonna get some
breakfast
ah what's the next weekly challenge
great question
so every uh the way we're doing it now
is
basically um
the
pro tier
discord
um members
come up with three prompts for the
weekly challenge
and issue it to the community the
community will vote on what the
challenge will be from the three
so
i'm gonna check the poll we're doing it
on the discord these days and it looks
like
challenge vote
between
nothing as a prompt
which i was hoping just like default
scene in whatever 3d no but like you can
get so advanced with it you can get so
advanced with nothing
yeah i think that's not a god
dude that's honestly a great idea i was
hoping for nothing nothing didn't win
[ __ ] people
people did not people did not want to do
nothing uh balance
and album cover with a song provided
they'd have to make an album cover oh
that's great that's great so album cover
came very close but balance there's
gonna be so many avengers uh
renders oh for balance yeah how so
because it's like the whole thanos thing
was like balancing the universe i see i
see yeah and like ian and yang there's
gonna be exactly
so that's the challenge this week on the
weekly challenge is balance uh check the
discord server and the link below
um
yeah do your best render based off of
balance and uh
yeah we'll announce it on the discord
server next week and it'll be sweet hell
yeah brother shout out to zenith super
chat enjoy that breakfast have extra
bacon on
that's so nice we're getting bacon
getting extra bacon yup hell yeah thanks
zenith appreciate it good stuff
there's a bacon-sized hole in my stomach
and you just filled it i know it's like
it's a little strip yeah
um i think that's it one i mean like
three more minutes here
any questions just at punisher here in
the chat
we'll answer any questions you all got
and we'll move on
with our with our days we'll move on
with our lives with our lives
um necco thanks for putting your top 100
absolutely great team in my life made my
day
absolutely cool yeah uh the pc water
cooled spillage oh that's great yeah
good one good one
uh what else
any questions waiting on them questions
are we coming to the uk anytime soon
were you weren't you trying to go
yeah i'm trying to go it's just tough
planning stuff and i i've been told that
now is not the time to go because of
covid and everything so probably
springtime i'll be visiting the uk so
i'll let you know let me know i would
love to join um that would be amazing oh
yeah and like i've only been to london
for like five hours oh really yeah and i
didn't try the indian food
damn it i know did you get a point
i did okay yeah i did i did
um tacos or burritos
depends on the day but burritos
for sure for sure i'm a taco guy like
burritos can just be a bit too heavy on
me i feel that i have to eat the whole
thing and i'm just like maxed out
yeah tacos there's more portion control
which is nice for sure
um
let's see
lighting tutorials in c4d i guess that'd
be for me um
lighting tutorials in c4d i mean
greyscale gorilla i learned most of my
stuff through grayscale gorilla and
octane jesus
just check them out octane jesus jesus
and grayscale gorilla they got some
amazing stuff um
and andre librov
check out his channel as well he has
some sick stuff
also i feel like watching um like
filmmaking lighting videos is super
helpful just learning like how to do
good lighting in general yeah because
it's the same thing yeah it's exactly
the same i'm just recreating it
do i like cheese
yes
yeah i love cheese yeah a little bit too
much sometimes
i like it in liquid form which is messed
up oh god you like nacho cheese oh okay
okay
yeah just get like i crack open a brie
and just gulp it down like
i always wanted to have a cheese rim
on my like like a martini or something
yes instead of salt you just dip it in
hot cheese and
it melts down the side and you can like
chew on it as you enjoy that's
ridiculous oh it's like the kind of
cheese that's left over on the
cheeseburger wrapper yep yeah the
in-n-out napkin yeah it's always a
cheese napkin oh god it's so good
oh man uh what else do we got any good
questions
have you joined a game jam no i just
started making games so maybe but i
don't feel confident enough my game
making abilities i guess i kind of did a
game jam at corridor when i made the
smash game was like sort of that was
sick thanks it was fun yeah you're doing
your games coming out maybe this year
hell yeah yeah um if you guys want to
check that out i mean i don't have
anything out for it yet but if you want
to follow me on instagram at peter
france i'll be releasing updates if you
like vr games it's uh it's
like an arcade style shooter with a with
a fun twist so a super crazy twist crazy
twist yeah yeah it gets cool thanks
um let's see
isn't it a little bit late for breakfast
nope never
um get out of here yeah
seriously but for all we love you uh
daniel
thank you for the super chat really
appreciate you thank you for the support
incredible talent you're showcasing how
do i reach you for sponsorship
opportunities um i think on my youtube i
just have
um there should be like a contact button
on my youtube it goes to uh
uh punisher direct gmail same for my
instagram it's on there um do you have a
do you have a business email yeah yeah
it's just contact peterjfrance.com heck
yeah yeah heck yeah um
favorite cheese mmm damn it
i gotta go brie
extra sharp uh cheddar that's a good one
too yeah do you ever just like
cut off
like a good block and just knock on it
yeah and then i put it in my jacket for
later yeah
sometimes you forget about it throw it
in the wash mm-hmm that's the best one
not using that pocket anymore
oh god that'd be rough
get it and mix it with some honey and
uh honey and
uh raisins or something i forgot it
sounds nice
who's my favorite celebrity who's your
favorite celebrity
i think owen wilson is great owen
wilson's great yeah i didn't say jackie
chan oh of course yeah
um
three more questions okay peter you can
choose one here
do i still make music yeah i actually
just put out a song if you'd like to
check it out on spotify and i've been
making a lot of music that i'm going to
be
putting out uh whenever it's good enough
to put out so we'll see what's your
spotify it's just peter france cool yeah
sweet uh choose another one
shoot okay i can scroll up you want yeah
your favorite celebrity
thank you for the compliment on my shirt
i got it at a great thrift store called
uh out of the closet in atwater village
nice we have one of those here oh really
yeah yeah great spot and i think um most
of the proceeds go to like uh
some charitable charitable costs like lg
lgbtq
plus
all them everything yes everything
um
any other last one last one for you this
is so much pressure
how do i handle the crippling
disappointment
that one's at you
that's a that's a mirror son
a mirror
a mirror
oh a mirror yeah yeah is that what you
were saying
or are we on no i was saying it was like
that was a question directed at you it
was like at podesta oh oh
i got you uh i don't i don't handle it
at all
i think that's the trick
yeah you just gotta move on you just
gotta feel it
don't push those feelings away you gotta
feel your feelings
do you have a name of the game you're
making no not yet okay
i gotta think of one yeah new to blender
any tips
um yes
uh watch the donut tutorial from andrew
price that's the classic um it's fun
making a donut and then just yeah find a
way to make it fun for yourself like
whatever excites you
move towards that don't
be working on what you think other
people are gonna like um
just make the kind of art that you would
enjoy looking at or experiencing and
that way
you'll be motivated to keep
you create a feedback loop you know
where you like you're working on a thing
and you like it so you keep going and
then you like get more so you keep going
and then it just pushes you
to work really hard on things when it
doesn't really feel like you're working
hard yep
it's fun you get addicted to like that
positive
i'm addicted to that dopamine
like working on something it's like this
is great yeah
but like sometimes it takes a long time
for a piece of art to get there and you
feel discouraged totally but you gotta
know that that's when you kick in the
like consistency and discipline but then
eventually you'll get to oh the renders
look nice and then you let the
that passion and inspiration take over
totally yeah yeah i have a bad habit of
sometimes like i'll start on something
and then i'm like i don't like this very
much then i'll just give up and move on
to the next thing it's not a good habit
yeah i mean it's
you know it's probably a lot of us do
that yeah um
and sometimes that just that's the way
it is you know that's just the way it
goes all right samuel thanks for the
super chat have you been to new zealand
before or plans to visit the future come
visit waita uh
come visit oh that's in new zealand
shoot dude yeah i um
i i'm thinking about moving to new
zealand are you for real i've never been
there so i should probably visit first
that might be a good idea
but um i literally
if i store it was like on google earth
for whatever reason i think i was like
doing vfx or something and i needed to
measure something anyways i i just did
the thing where you like go to a random
point in the map and zoom in all the way
it's like where am i and i was like this
is beautiful where is this it was new
zealand and then of course i was curious
um
i was
a little high so i was like going down
this rabbit hole and i was like what is
it like to live in new zealand and just
googled that and it brought up the um
like new zealand immigration page like
they want americans oh wow to come and
live there and it was like giving you
all the reasons like amazing work-life
balance like lots of outdoor activities
big outdoor cultures it sounds great
universal healthcare everybody's super
chill you can find every type of uh
natural biome there oh my god it just
sounds amazing and so i
if i'm going to go visit and if i like i
might move there for a couple years sick
yeah
yeah that's awesome i love the idea of
like moving to another country that's
definitely something it's a dream of
mine to like live in japan for a year or
two or something haven't you visited
visited oh yeah multiple multiple times
i love it that's great have you been to
new zealand no
never you want to go absolutely all
right the freaking hobbit tour
yeah that's probably packed out
everyone's doing that but yeah um thank
you all thank you so much um y'all are
great good times all around thank you
peter for hanging out yeah um
just dropped that patreon last week link
in the description get on the expanding
machines uh contest it's basically a
raffle random drawing gonna choose four
winners to win some cool prizes from
nvidia and pny going to the 30th of this
month and check out peter's patreon and
all of his stuff is down in the
description thanks bud thank you guys oh
yeah it's been a great time it's been
great uh judging these we're not even
judging just
chilling
yeah vibing absolutely all right y'all
peace out see ya
[Music]
so
[Music]
you